Hello!
Howdy doody!
Howdy!
Howdy howdy!
Get him loud.
Wait, how am I... Am I okay?
Sorry, I just did some stuff.
I just did some stuff.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Howdy do!
Ah, ah, ah... Yes.
Come on, everybody!
Welcome, we!
Welcome back to Oblivion.
I'll be honest.
Might be my last Oblivion.
Maybe for a while.
Maybe in general.
I don't know, I'm feeling... I don't know...
I don't know, I'm just feeling a little... I'm not burnt out from it.
But I think I played a lot of it at the beginning and then, you know...
I like the side quest so much more than the actual story.
And so, I just... I'm like, oh, well, you know...
I could quote-unquote beat the game.
But like, I like the side quest so much more.
Tudius Sextius must die today then.
Yeah, I would like to do that.
I would like to murder him.
And the other brother.
But yeah...
Friendship with Oblivion ended.
Time for Skyrim.
Yeah, I got my house.
I think the last thing that I...
The big last thing I wanted to do was...
Was murder those people.
Of course I want to do more murdering.
I really like the murder.
Sorry, I was moving stuff.
But yeah...
Yeah, we'll see.
You know...
Hehehehe.
Rip and tear.
But...
You know...
I was like, what can I do today?
For...
For in the middle...
I'm trying to figure out...
I want to do like a mid...
Day stream.
Maybe Fridays.
Kind of get you through that.
Well, Friday is exciting.
Because it's the weekend.
Weekend.
It's Friday.
Friday.
Imagine Minto accidentally finishes...
The DLCs before the main quest.
All...
Wait, DLC?
What's the DLC?
Minto Friday.
It's Friday, everybody.
And...
It's...
August.
Happy August!
Good night, Brandon!
Happy, happy August.
You're invited to a double date?
Which wife are you bringing?
Think quick!
Um...
Ha...
Uh...
Koharu!
Blue Archive Koharu!
Hehehehe.
She...
August already.
That's how I feel.
I feel.
Oh my goodness.
Hyemma!
Welcome to Bamboo Shiptakiel.
What's the DLC?
Wait a second!
I never even got to see the...
...
Lady!
How do I find her?
Oh wait, there was that guy, too, who was just like, I'm your biggest fan.
That's the DLC!
Oh, how to fake your funds.
Thank you!
Paying tax on my recently acquired Minky shirt, boss.
Thanks for ordering it, Azure!
Thank you!
Did I get the DLC?
How do I know?
DLC...
Deluxe upgrade?
Wait...
Is it the deluxe upgrade?
Oh, I have it already!
It's done!
No way?
Really?
It's included...
Ah!
Oh, how do you find vengeance?
DLC these nights?
Okay.
Present them.
Where are they?
I'm calling you out on your bluff.
Present them.
While I earn a dollar, I earn a dime.
That's why I watch Minky on Company Time!
Yahoo!
Okay.
Well, maybe we can find her.
What did we last do?
Brother?
Oh!
That's the guy I tried to kill, no?
I like how I saved literally...
Oh, this is an autosave.
It's like...
10 seconds later.
Yeah!
I was sneaking into his house to try and kill him!
Master's on the phone, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Minky had a fun time at the ecchi con.
She got to go to a mini cafe and get a picture with a blue archive cosplayer!
Did she post?
Did she post it?
Is this one of the brothers I'm trying to kill?
Oh, I guess so.
He knows that I'm like trying to sneak into his house.
Wait!
Can you guys tell me how to...
Can you guys tell me...
Where's the nene nene lady?
Where?
Hi Minto.
Hello!
You seem a lot better today.
Yeah!
I'm usually...
I was...
I was better yesterday.
In the shivering aisles.
Water?
The best type of nut.
I like cashews.
Is this an aisle?
Wait.
Nope.
Check the lake next to Brazil.
Where's Brazil?
It's not here.
Mentioning this before I forget to.
I recently saw your cover of Kansankobody yesterday.
I instantly fell in love with your voice.
Thank you, Robin!
Thank you!
Good afternoon, Meantown.
Good afternoon, Phil!
Thank you for the very spooky Donald.
See that...
Michi made a drawing of me.
Wait, what?
She did?
When?
In the big bay near...
Breville!
Okay.
There's an island with a magic door.
It must be this!
Oh!
I was right the first time I felt it.
In my...
Ectoplasmic bones!
Wow!
Let's see how I fight the gatekeeper monster, then go to the mania side.
It's called...
The quest is called Strange Door in...
Nib...
Nibren Bay.
Okay.
Alright!
We can go!
Where am I now?
I'm right here, right?
Yeah, we're doing paranoia.
Hello!
Hello?
I'm not trying to murder.
What is it?
Nothing.
I'm trying...
What is it now?
I'm trying to murder!
Wait.
This isn't his house.
That's Glarthur's house.
We'll kill him later.
This is it.
If I go in, he gets mad at me.
Happy Friday!
Even if you're not coming to Otaku Town this year, I'm still hoping...
To meet my fellow wisps at my hometown convention next weekend.
Thank you for streaming during functioning weeb hours.
Yeah!
Have fun!
Oh.
Hello.
Why is everybody hating on me?
Bunch of haters.
My tea be hot.
The tea?
There's piping.
Oh my god.
You think I could just go inside now?
Oh shoot!
I forgot sea...
Well...
Might as well use it.
I thought sea was Crouch.
Uh...
Is that him right there?
Aw man.
How'd you know?
I'm David of Surili Brothers Vineyard.
Gaston is my brother.
From our vineyards come the finest wines in Tamriel.
Yeah, I gotta kill you.
Finer than Tamika's?
Yeah, well, in all honesty, no.
But our wines are very good.
And much cheaper than Tamika's very fine product, I assure you.
Glarthor.
Our neighbor.
A bit eccentric.
Why?
Is there something I should know?
No.
Never mind.
Very well.
Bye.
Can I walk in around them?
Wait, he's not following me.
I think he's actually fine.
I'm stealing.
I've stolen...
Oh, this is the wrong door.
I don't learn my lesson, everybody.
Everyone.
I've never learned my lesson.
Not even once.
I've never learned my lesson, even once.
I always go for the root.
And I always go into the wrong door.
My gosh.
Eat Tina.
You okay?
Oh!
Now it's locked!
Okay, he really doesn't want us around.
What's your story?
Oh, how's your wine?
What can I do for you?
Wait, Tamika.
Gosh!
I thank you so much for the best gift of...
Why?
Thank you!
Harwin is another one of those goblin hunters at the Fighters Guild.
She's always talking about her goblin killing tactics.
Good day.
All right.
I think we can give up on this quest for now.
I'm gonna fast travel to...
Braville.
Sorry, Glarther.
Well, that will be the grand finale of death.
Probably.
Oh, have I been here before?
Hello.
Hi.
I don't think so.
It looks like a summer camp.
Why is it always raining?
Un golem.
I'm sorry, but I'm really not one for engaging in conversation.
Please, leave me.
Wow.
Lucky old lady.
Wait, you can reach up, kiss the lucky old lady on the cheek, and hope you'll get your wish?
Okay.
All right, everybody.
Kiss me on the cheek.
What the?
Uh-oh.
I think he stole it from me.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm sorry, but I'm really not one friend.
Okay.
We need to leave.
Kiss this old lady on the cheek.
He's stomping around.
I see you're a follower of the Gray Fox, too.
How'd you know?
Oh, okay.
See you later.
Sorry.
Can you spare a coin?
Wretched are you?
Who gives these people these names?
Do you think they pick them themselves?
Which cheek?
What about you?
What's your name?
Me children are starving.
Please help.
What are you cheating in?
Cards.
How do I get out of this town?
I'm stuck at summer camp.
How are you?
Is this a door?
What are you guarding?
Me children are starving.
Oh, here we go.
Wait.
Uh.
Yes?
Let's try this bridge over here.
Me children are starving.
Okay, well, you know.
Oh, oh shoot.
Oh.
I almost didn't make it.
Parkour.
Who are you?
Greenum.
Someone who is actually kind to me.
I'm the city swimmer.
Does anyone see city swimmer?
Is he gliding beneath the silver water?
Is he creeping round a corner, hugging a wall, silent as a shadow in the dark?
No, I am here.
I stand proud before you, city swimmer, trainer of the perspective sneaker, the sly sliding unseen.
I found you very easily.
What?
You have not eyes to see?
The castle, of course.
The only challenge worthy of a swift sneaker.
Farewell.
What is she yapping about?
I actually don't get it.
I'm the city swimmer.
Why aren't you the city sneaker?
Sounds like you're not doing your job very well.
If you're supposed to be sneaking, but everyone sees you swimming.
Yes.
Here we go.
Wait.
Yeah, this should be good.
I would love to be an Oblivion NPC.
What?
Oh, never mind.
This is not...
I'm listening.
This is not a door to the outside.
It did say great hall, but I thought it would be an outside hall.
It literally said castle.
You know...
It says great hall.
It doesn't say castle.
Yes, it does.
You're right.
I...
What's this about?
Is she...
Is she swimming?
What's your name?
Breville.
Hello?
You exist?
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
I'm sorry to impose upon you like this, but I'm in need of assistance and I don't know what to do.
My husband, Alaron, is missing.
Please explain how a hall can be outside.
Look.
I never claimed to be a hall expert like you.
Look at how smiley she is.
She even put on makeup.
Those lips are not natural.
It all started when Alaron became foolish and started gambling.
He's foolish!
He'd visit the arena every week and spend our hard-earned money on bets.
I told him to stop, but he didn't listen.
He was certain he could win us a fortune and move us somewhere nicer, like the Imperial City.
It didn't take long for Alaron to begin losing.
I would hate to...
He resorted to borrowing money from a usurer to cover his losses and place new bets.
Live in a time without umbrellas.
As you can imagine, it didn't pay off.
He ended up owing around 500 gold.
He could never have that kind of money to pay back the usurer.
How much money do I have?
Well, what happened to him?
I think your man got by the Mafia.
The usurer does not sound like a real person.
To meet him at the Lonely Suitor Lodge.
He hasn't returned since.
I fear for his life.
Her teeth look weird.
She's got a bit of an underbite, yeah.
Please, I'm not wealthy, but I'd give anything to see Alaron again.
Actually, she really looks like a...
Like a...
An alien disguised as a human.
There's just something really uncanny about her.
I'll help you.
I will?
Oh, yeah, I will.
Please be careful.
I don't wish any harm to befall you either.
It's the way her neck sticks out like at an angle.
I don't... I don't know.
Goodbye.
Farewell and be careful.
Curtain is not to be trusted.
Who's Curtain?
Hello.
Okay, here we go, here we go.
Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Hi, Mito.
I never use umbrellas as the nine divines in ten...
Okay.
We still have never found my horse.
If I fast travel to a stable, my horse will appear!
And he never has!
My
horse will be here somewhere.
Oops, sorry, oh gosh, I'm trying to remember how to play this game.
If you are looking to buy a horse, go inside and talk to Isabeau.
Isabeau!
Nah, I have a horse.
Good day!
Go ahead!
Oh, it stopped raining!
I'm about to go swim!
Is that our...
Is that our little island?
Wait, wait.
Or is that our little island?
Wait, there's so many little islands?
Ah!
That...
That is our island, I think.
Must be gold ship.
What's on that one island?
It looks like a man side profile with a nose.
Let's go check it out.
I'm swimming.
Oh, I can't...
Wait, go up.
Oh, please.
I can't see.
There we go.
I won't get attacked in the water, will I?
Go find out.
I am!
What the...
Oh, there's people.
Definitely...
Foes.
Not friends.
Wait, it is a face!
Wait, it is a...
Oh my gosh!
Sneaky.
Come on.
Come on, get up there.
Sneak, sneak.
Kill him.
What the heck is...
A strange door?
Is this the door?
Kill!
Wait, did they die?
Wait.
No?
Are they friends?
Actually, I can't tell.
Look.
Um...
It wasn't me!
Oops.
Uh, hold on, hold on.
Don't run.
It was...
Could have been a literal mosquito.
I found a strange...
Door.
Why are they running?
Not my arrow, officer.
Wait, are they gone?
Oh, no.
Wait, please!
Please!
It's not right!
Here comes another one!
Madness!
Why?
Everything is wrong!
It can't be done!
Stay away from me!
Here comes another one!
You can't make me go back!
I will kill you all!
You're all going to die!
Stay back!
This one's violent!
Ah!
Ha!
Good job, Mr. Ha!
Sorry.
I'd rather not think so much for the five gifted.
Strange door.
I don't know where it came from, and I don't want to.
Those who've gone in have come back out...
Wrong.
I'm just here to warn folks to stay away.
Is this it?
Is this the...
What happened to them?
Look for yourself!
Their brains are addled!
Got no sense!
Hmm...
I'm going in.
Ha!
It's your funeral.
I'm just here to warn people, not keep them out.
Go ahead in!
I'll be here to clean up the mess when you come out.
Got no sense!
Can I take...
What's he got?
He's got some scruffy shoes.
Where's the hallelujah?
Unworthy!
Useless mortal meat!
Walking bag of dumb!
I'm going in!
What?
Who said that?
Oh my gosh!
This is so mysterious and fun!
Wait, come here!
Come here!
A nice effort though!
Shame is dead!
These things happen...
Zora's fleeing for their life!
Ha!
Bring me a champion!
Rend the flesh of my foes!
A mortal champion!
To wade through the entrails of my...
I think I scared him!
Ha!
Wait, is the...
Is the door talking to me?
Really?
Do come in!
It's lovely in the aisles right now.
Perfect time for a visit.
Am I going crazy already?
Let's go.
Taking a...
Black tar.
Let's go.
Re-listen to your karaoke's every now and then.
I forgot you sang Wind Nocturne for the first Lunar game.
Yeah!
I just played and beat that game quite recently.
Still playing the second Lunar.
Yeah!
I did play...
I did sing that!
Hello?
There we go.
Is there anything else in here?
Okay, let's go in.
To the fringe!
Yahoo!
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Was it you talking to me?
Let's be civil, shall we?
Please, have a seat.
Okay.
I'm sitting.
Yes?
What can I do for you?
I imagine you're here above the door.
Uh-huh.
Strange door.
Yes.
You have entered, and now you are here.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Truly.
Are you the jester?
Who are you?
I am Haskell, Chamberlain to the Lord Sheogorath.
Okay.
What is this place?
You approach the Shivering Isles.
Through the door behind me lies the realm of Sheogorath, Prince of Madness, Lord of the Neverthead.
Oh wait, you guys said I have to fight something, right?
Why did that door appear?
Because my lord wills it to be so.
It poses no danger to Mundus.
No compact has been violated.
It is a doorway.
An invitation.
Perhaps you will accept it for what it is.
What do you want with me?
For you?
I do not know.
My lord seeks a mortal to act as his champion.
I'm the champion!
I'm the hero!
And to fathom it is a foolish endeavor.
He looks so disgusted with me.
His will is his own.
His reality follows suit.
You are here because you chose to enter.
You were not summoned.
And the people outside?
They entered this realm and were ill-prepared.
Their minds are now the property of my lord.
How can they be cured?
Well...
Murdered that guy.
Cured?
You speak as if they are diseased.
They live now in another state of being.
Perhaps it is you who needs a cure.
Free run?
Foot licker.
Thank you for...
the gift and...
Thank you.
What happens now?
You do as you will.
You may leave the way you entered.
Your life will be none the worse for your time spent here.
Okay.
Yeah.
You may continue onward.
Through the door behind me.
If you can pass the gates of madness, perhaps the Lord Sheogorath will find a use for you.
Yeah.
And if I go through the door?
Who is to say?
There are always choices to be made.
The realm of madness is no different in that regard.
Your choices are your own.
Enter or do not, but make your decision.
I have other duties to which I must attend.
Do you?
You're just sitting here.
Speak with me again when you have made up your mind.
The anticipation is almost too much to bear.
Anticipation.
The madness of Pelagius.
Well?
I'm ready.
Have you made up your...
Yeah, I'll do it.
Fine.
I'm sure my Lord will be most pleased.
Let me in!
Assuming you ever manage to see him.
Open the door!
You'll want to pass through the gates of madness.
Oh, and mind the gatekeeper.
He dislikes strangers to the realm.
Okay.
Enjoy your stay.
Oh, yeah!
Get up.
How do I get up again?
Shoot, I can't remember.
Get up.
I'm...
I'm glued to the seat.
Uh...
E...
F...
T?
No.
Uh...
Space?
No.
Whoa.
I've tried that.
I can't...
Whoa.
I can't get up, you guys.
I can't get up.
What if I go and sit in that chair instead?
Oh, wait.
I...
I tried E.
It didn't work either.
I tried moving!
I have entered the Shivering Isles.
In order to find the Lord of this realm, I must first pass through the gates of madness.
Well, this is fine, actually.
This is so Alice of Wonderland!
I'll take some congealed putrid essence.
I'll take some of this.
Take everything.
Everything's a souvenir.
Everything's a souvenir!
I don't know who's friend or foe here.
So I'm...
I'm...
Being cautious.
Like, well this...
This looks like it'll throw up on me.
Save the cane.
Do save.
He looks...
Oh, unfriendly.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Give me my stuff back.
I kinda wanna...
Wait.
Can I pick him up?
How do you pick up people again?
Eat.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah.
Move.
Move your body.
Wait.
There we go.
I wanna get a good ol' look at you.
Mr. Welp.
Come on, come on.
Don't be...
Don't be so...
It's me.
The Welp.
Yeah.
I'm here in the fringe.
It's been a hard day for him.
He keeled over two times.
Oh!
He might be alive.
Oh wait, this is me.
I'm still holding him.
What's that?
It's a young balewog.
I saw someone say, beware the water.
Well, I touched it.
Oops.
On accident.
It's a balewog.
What is this?
Can I breathe it?
Just like you on the floor last stream.
Uh oh.
Hold on.
I think I need to...
Close out of wallpaper engine.
Frog Bird really let himself go.
Don't say that.
I'm still lagging a little bit.
It's cause I think we're in a new area.
I've got more black tar.
Wow.
Is this safe to breathe?
I still think one of these are gonna...
Is gonna throw up like a...
I got a digestive slime.
I think it's gonna throw up like a person or something, you know?
Yummy spores.
Mm-hmm.
I'm crawling along.
Which way do we go?
I'm in the fringe!
Wait, are these the aisles?
Veil of suicides.
Okay.
What kind of wallpapers are you rocking?
I have...
I have the new Seiya.
Um...
Seiya.
Blue Archive.
Her driving the car.
And then the other one I have is...
Is...
Hina.
Blue Archive.
Okay.
The hill of minecrafting.
This place should be fine though.
It's...
Maybe a village.
With skulls.
And...
Nice.
Where'd the other guy go?
Yeah.
You.
I'm not so weak.
Is he climbing the tree?
Oh, no.
Or not.
Or...
Oh my God.
He's fast.
There's another guy down there.
Didn't even notice.
Stupid.
We gotta be on our toes around here.
A...
Grumite arrow.
Ooh.
Good try.
Thank you.
Ooh.
I'm on my toes.
My tippy toes.
Ooh.
The music sounds way too...
Oh my gosh.
This guy has gold.
For what reason?
Why is the music so calming?
This place is not.
Um...
He's looking right at me.
Got Hanako's swimsuit yet?
Yes.
I do have her.
Fine.
I did get her finally.
Yes.
You got anything good?
Oh, he's got that congealed putrid essence.
Is that...
A thing?
I'm gonna shoot it.
Okay.
I've got eggs!
This is how they're born!
Huh.
No family reunion happening today.
I'll tell you that.
Just don't shoot innocents.
Am I killing innocent people?
I don't think so.
Cook the eggs.
I'll...
I will get a disease.
Did I...
He doesn't have me.
Yeah, I took my arrow.
Think of the protein.
Oh, he's doing his squats!
My marksman increased.
Let's go.
It's...
What was he doing?
Am I...
Do I need to be in here or...
I'm kinda confused.
We're just exploring.
I need to get to the lady that goes...
And I will feel so satisfied.
Holy!
Thought I heard something behind me.
What's her name?
Magus Beater?
Putting some muscle in those legs.
Hey, it's how we get the...
There's a door!
I think this is what I saved, yeah.
Let's go.
Zedifan.
Guys!
Is this where I'm supposed to be?
Am I in the right spot?
No idea.
What is that?
Oh.
Oh my god.
How did I miss?
Ow!
Three!
Give me my arrows!
Is that a trap?
Maybe this is a dungeon.
You don't need to be here right now.
Dungeons are so scary in this game.
For what reason?
You don't need to be here.
You don't need to be here right now.
Ah!
Pilot's Ballad!
Welcome to Bad Fuship!
What you got?!
Dang!
I'll take that...
Madness Ore?
That sounds exciting.
All these...
Daggers are...
They sell for...
Not bad price.
Actually, I don't even know...
How much money do I have?
Seventy!
I'm broke!
Aw, shoot, wait.
Okay, I have a lot of space still.
Oh, wait, I killed it.
Nice.
The price of homeowner.
Shit boy!
I love my three times damage.
Might be the best thing I've ever invested.
What the hell?
I was like, he's still breathing.
It looks like a dog.
What?
And his belly is scratched.
Where's that good boy?
Where's that good belly bug?
Oh, ew.
I was afraid of that being a trap or something.
Yes!
He wants belly rubs.
Yeah!
Um, um, um, um.
A spoon!
Oh, he's got some eggies.
Damn, it's magical.
I don't want to start taking everything.
Oh, wait.
Is this...
Oh, okay.
Oh!
I'm still a pro at this.
It said easy, but it was actually...
So tricky.
Sounded like a...
Like a...
Like a trap.
Metal door.
When in doubt, follow the red green marker.
Yeah!
I'm having fun exploring a little bit though.
I...
Give up.
I call!
I was sabotaged!
What is this?
Oh, just an outlook.
The urn!
Why are there potions in the urn?
I don't need luck.
I get by on my own.
Everything.
I've gotten this far with zero luck stat.
I don't need it anymore.
Okay.
We'll come back here.
I thought it might be the place where I have to fight the guy.
The...
The gatekeeper or whatever it is.
It's a minky.
That's me.
Minky.
Wow.
Okay, let's go the other way now.
Minky.
See, it feels so, like, calm here.
Is the water safe?
You guys are scaring me.
Is it just if I drink it, I go crazy?
I'm okay with a little crazy.
Gardens of flesh and bone.
Haha.
167 steps ahead.
Lucky us.
I'm gonna become...
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine like a...
Like a...
What's the word?
Like a travel vlogger in Oblivion.
Oh my god, guys.
Let me tell you about this hidden gem in Kyrodil.
It's called the Gardens of Flesh and Bone.
Whoa.
Wait, these are actual homes.
Whoa!
I feel like I'm in Atlantis.
Today we're checking out the Eternal Tortured Labyrinth.
Now, don't let the name fool you.
It's actually...
A crazy...
Awesome place to get photos.
If you're looking for a cute little spot...
To just rest and relax for all of eternity...
Then this place has got you.
Where am I?
I'm still in the fringe.
I'm supposed to go this way.
Okay.
Now I'm sold.
Wait, can I visit these people?
Are you friends?
They look like friends, no?
Wait, hold on.
Is this like a living town?
Ugh, I can't see.
Hello.
Hello?
They should have listened to me.
With these dramatic pauses.
We'll be swimming in blood soon.
What?
Yuck.
Wait, why?
Let's go watch.
Oh.
Just as long as we don't catch any of their diseases.
Adventurers always get strange diseases.
Oh, look at the membership.
Thank you!
What are you doing?
It'll be fun watching them get knocked around up there.
Sorry, I'm lagging a little bit.
You'll follow.
Just don't get any blood on me.
Oh!
Wait!
They didn't...
Okay.
The wastrel's purse.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
I think this place is...
Oh!
She's awa- She's awake!
Hello!
Hello.
I'm Dredwyn.
No one was running this place when I got here.
They left plenty of things behind, though.
The pocket guide to the empire.
What do you need?
Oh, cute!
A gatekeeper?
He protects the gates of madness.
He'll kill anyone who gets near.
Oh, she is tired.
He's about to destroy some adventurers up there now.
Why do you talk so slow?
I took over the inn when I got here.
There wasn't anyone living here.
Except for Sheldon.
He says he's mayor.
Don't believe it.
Is she drunk?
See you later.
She's dead again!
She's- she's- oh!
The- This is me on the train when I'm trying not to fall asleep.
Going back to my hotel!
In Japan!
I'm like...
Okay, I think she's good.
Wait, so there are people in here and they're normal- wow.
What's the occasion?
Why are you bothering me with that wagging tongue?
Do you know how long it would waggle after I rip it from your mouse?
My mouse?
Don't tempt me.
Squeaker squeaks!
Wait, come here, come here.
If you think I'm interested in whatever you're selling, you're wrong.
I'm not.
Why don't you go play with the gatekeeper?
Run along now.
The gatekeeper.
You want to know about my child?
Your child?
Go see for yourself.
He guards the gates at the top of the hill.
Be warned.
He doesn't play nice.
That's a madness.
One leads to mania.
One to dementia.
Two shades of madness.
You're not getting in because you're not blessed by Sheogorath.
You can try to get the keys.
My lord had them sewn into my child's body.
I wonder if you are a fast pleader.
Or a slow pleader.
Oh.
What's the rumors?
If you see a shambles dying, stand back.
They'll take you with them.
What's a shambles?
How I look forward to our goodbyes.
What's in your room?
Oh my god.
Sharon with the class?
Oh.
She's got a skull, a scythe.
Oh my god.
Some legs.
You try my patience.
Out with it.
No.
No, no, no.
Oh, see.
This one's nice and clean.
I love an inn with two rooms.
I guess you don't get many passengers.
Not passengers.
Pass...
Passerbys.
This is normal.
Is it?
Yeah?
Sheldon!
Oh.
Who's that?
Handsome fella.
Love to see it.
And he's an artiste?
Okay.
I don't think Sheldon's here.
What is that?
Oh, it's a madness ore.
You think I'm gonna go crazy?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm excited for it.
I welcome the madness.
So you guys said beware the water.
Or I still have one person.
I might have gotten one guide.
But I'm taking it to heart.
Nanette Dawn.
I'm crazy!
Oh, she looks normal.
Hello.
I'm Nanette Dawn.
I wasn't sure why I came here until she showed up.
Now I know.
I'm going to be a powerful sorceress.
Just like Romina.
I can't tell- Do you hear that sound?
Oh.
It's like a host dying.
I can't tell if any of these people are abnormal or not, because they act and look all the same as the people in...
in Cryodil, so it doesn't really...
He's the crowning achievement of Romina Varenum.
She's my teacher.
The gatekeeper keeps our people who don't belong.
I belong.
I saw some strangers heading up there earlier.
If they're still alive, you can see the gatekeeper in action.
It's glorious.
Wait, I kind of... wait.
Is it those two guys that left?
Goodbye.
Maybe I should have gone and watched them.
They're probably still around, though.
The Fringe.
Oh, they went to watch.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Because they were like, Don't give blood on me.
Okay, never mind.
I thought this would be like up the...
I thought this was a little...
A little shortcut.
I'm not... I don't want to break my knees.
Them eyes be twitching mint.
No, she seems so... so kind.
Okay, so they went...
Yeah, this way.
Okay, up the hill.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna face the madness.
The gatekeeper.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I see, I see.
Okay, come on.
I'm gonna save real quick.
Oh, that was an auto save, but whatever.
You there.
Stay away from the gatekeeper.
Let us handle this.
Wait, can I...
Oh.
I'm fellas Sarandas.
Don't breathe on me.
Okay.
Actually, I want to watch.
Bye.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
They should have listened to me.
Woo, woo, woo.
Wow, that guy's kind of big.
You think I should join in?
You think they'll...
A really slow fight.
No?
Let them handle it?
I think they're doing a good job.
The guy's barely moving.
Wait, they're swinging?
They miss?
He doesn't even...
He's not even attacking them.
Um...
He's stunlocked.
Wait, they might actually win?
He's a gentle giant.
They got this?
Uh...
Hello.
Oh, Sheldon!
I went in your house.
Hello, I'm Sheldon.
I've been here the longest.
That's why I'm mayor of Passwall.
That, and because I'm the best at being in charge.
I see.
Welcome to my town.
Thank you.
Uh, the gatekeeper.
He guards the gates of madness.
See for yourself.
He's about to destroy a party of adventurers.
I think they are getting...
He's getting his ass handed to him.
Hi, mate.
Let me show you a cupcake.
Thank you so much for the super job.
Thank you.
Goodbye.
Guys, I think I should help them.
I don't know.
If this part is bugged, maybe I should do something.
What?
Oh.
I thought he was gonna do something.
Wait!
Oh.
I don't think it's cause he's cornered, guys.
I think they're just, uh...
Can I walk past?
I wonder which one gives me dementia.
Ah, I need a key.
Haskell mentioned that the gates were guarded by the gatekeeper.
He must have the keys.
What if I...
Okay, hold on.
Pickpocket!
You can't pickpocket the guy.
Hahaha.
It did...
She did mention that it was like buried into his flesh.
Um...
Hmm...
But you know...
It was worth a shot.
I can get my grubby little hands in anywhere.
Uh oh.
Do your worst.
Do anything.
Hahaha.
Show me what you've got.
Wow, we can get real up and close though.
Wow!
What's the matter?
I'm getting tired?
Reload game.
Yes.
I think he's glitched a little bit.
Hahaha.
You there!
Stay away from the gatekeeper!
Let us handle this!
Oh!
He's doing it!
Uh oh.
No gatekeeper, please!
Oh!
He's doing it!
He's...
Hahaha.
Oh, they're bleeding all over the place!
The formidable gatekeeper has destroyed a party of adventurers.
I had to talk to the residents of Paswa before trying to deal with this creature.
Ah, you almost made it!
Look at that crazy armor!
Where'd you get the... the foot?
Alright, here we go.
Who's J-Red?
Hmm...
One to the lands of Mania and one to Dementia.
The gatekeeper makes sure no one gets in who isn't supposed to.
Breathe on him.
It's a nice enough place.
Less dirty than others.
I feel like I belong.
That old man in the room made out of butterflies.
He said to wait here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The Mariana in the broom... yeah, we saw him too.
Rumors.
I don't like you, and don't want to talk to you.
Wait if I... okay, hold on, hold on.
This better be good.
We're time... time to...
uh... maybe...
get some info out of our little friend here.
No, you do me too much honor.
Uh...
Uh-oh.
Remarkable.
Bah.
You can't scare me.
Ooh!
Okay, that wasn't great.
Really now.
You're such...
Oh, please.
Bah.
Remarkable.
Okay, okay.
Uh...
Nice.
Not funny.
Not even... goodness.
What can I say?
You can't scare me.
Really.
46.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Have you watched the Oblivion gamer poops?
I haven't.
Smile.
Angry.
Sweet.
Sister.
Sadistic.
Oh...
This is not good.
What a great story.
You're revolting.
Goodness.
You're wasting your breath.
54!
Wait a second.
Do I have my thing out?
No.
Wait, hold on.
Don't leave.
Hello, I'm Sheldon.
I've been here the longest.
Oopsie.
That's why I'm mayor of...
Welcome!
Okay, uh...
Gatekeeper.
He guards the gates of madness.
Don't get too close to him.
He'll kill you.
And it will leave a mess in my town.
Yeah.
J Red Ice Veins wants to kill the gatekeeper.
Okay, so we gotta go find J Red Ice Veins.
J Red.
Alright, thank you.
Take care.
Bye!
J Red.
J Red Ice Veins.
What a name.
What a guy.
Over there?
I guess?
Is that our J Red friend?
You guys, I'm afraid.
Someone said to be aware of the water, but I gotta swim.
Oh, oh shoot.
My legs!
Ouch!
My acrobatics increased somehow.
Okay, I'm swimming.
There was nothing to be afraid of.
Wait, can I level up?
J Red Ice Veins.
I'm J Red Ice Veins.
Do you ever wonder why things look better without their skin on?
For instance, you can only really see the bones when you take them out.
You can hear them better that way, too.
I have no bones.
Does that make me more attractive?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, was he saying that no bones is like...
Like...
You know?
Is he flirting with me?
Oh, he's nodding!
I want him dead.
I need him dead.
His bones are calling to me.
Yeah.
Rumor has it you want him dead, too.
If you're any good with a lockpick, we can help each other out.
We can get into the gardens of flesh and bone.
Sorry, I just took a sippy of my tea.
Ah!
Me with the lockpick?
You have asked the right madam.
They say the gatekeeper's magical.
I don't believe in magic.
But I do believe in bones.
And the best way to kill something is with the bones of its own.
Hell yeah.
I can see the bones of a dead gatekeeper in the courtyard of the gardens.
The door's locked, though.
You'll pick that lock, and I'll collect the bones.
Then I'll make some arrows, and we'll kill the gatekeeper.
Sound good?
Yeah!
Lead on!
Here, take this lockpick.
Careful!
It's the only one I've got.
You open the door, I'll kill things.
Let's go!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited right now.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Wait, where'd he go?
Okay.
Hold on, mister.
Oh, it auto-saved.
We're good.
Okay, just kidding.
This is so exciting.
J-Red, my man!
I try...
Oh, okay.
Hard...
Hard left.
That's fine.
You know the way.
Okay, zigzagging.
Let's go.
Okay, that's fine.
Garden of flesh and bones?
I...
Oh, I guess we didn't...
I saw that it was on the map, but we didn't go up here.
Okay.
Hurry, pick that lock open.
I can hear them in there.
Okay.
Oh, it's very easy.
What?
I was expecting...
Something more difficult.
Uh-oh.
J-Red, don't die on me.
Oh, I don't think he's coming for you.
Good job.
From these gatekeeper bones, I can make some arrows.
Yes.
When will these bone arrows be ready?
Find me in a few hours.
We'll kill the gatekeeper.
Okay.
Bone arrows.
The arrows aren't ready yet.
Come back later.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
See ya.
Well...
Does that mean I can't get any bones for myself?
Leave me alone.
Ouch.
Yeah, leave me alone.
Activate?
Wait, wait.
Uh...
I don't think I meant to press that.
Wait.
Wait, wait.
What do you mean activate?
There's another guy.
I hear the music.
Oh, never mind.
But what if?
What if we save?
Do save.
And then activate.
Activate, activate, activate.
Okay, nothing happens.
Just kidding.
Needs a key.
Wow.
I think J Red is my fave Oblivion NPC.
He's pretty cool.
I can't tell if I'm in active battle or if it's just the music being...
Exciting.
Okay.
I like these things, but I still am afraid of them.
Yeah.
Any more skellies?
None.
We can go sleep.
And we'll level up.
And then that will be a few hours.
Those are hungers.
Well, why don't they eat?
What will they be after?
Once they have a hearty meal.
The fullers.
Am I going the right way?
This way.
Hungers are terrifying.
Wait, you can actually fight them?
I don't like that.
Greetings.
Hello.
I like your town.
I would stay here.
They're on a diet.
I'm going...
I'm going to partake in your bed.
Sleep for...
What?
Like three hours?
That's a couple of hours.
Nope.
A nice little nap.
I'm level nine!
Oh!
Thank
you so much for the bread!
Everybody, hello!
Let's see.
I just leveled up.
Hold on.
Show the details.
How fast you can move.
That's always good.
Right back.
Thanks for the fine gifter!
How goes the Elder Scrolls?
Yeah?
They're old.
Take up.
Thanks for the gifter!
Rock my Robin.
Thank you for the fine gifter!
Thank you so much for the gifter!
I forgot she made E.T.
No, it's E.T.
Na!
I'm E.T.
Look at her.
You can't tell because I have my robe on.
But...
She's got...
A nice...
Like...
Goldilocks.
Yeah...
Scarily accurate E.T.
The key takes to the five gifs!
Let's see.
Um...
Max agility.
I think maybe we could do more strength...
So that we can carry more stuff.
You know?
Let's do like...
Three.
Endurance...
Is my health.
I don't have a very good personality.
I like being fast, also.
Oh, I forgot I can only pick three things...
And then I have to stick to them.
I think maybe like this.
Fast!
We'll make it even.
Look at that.
Look how even that is.
Four, four, four.
All spooky.
Yes.
Do you have bulbous fingers, E.T.
Not asking for a friend?
Why?
This should be fun.
Okay.
Good morning...
World.
Oh!
Wait, who are you?
I don't mind talking down to your level.
Oh, wait.
Hi.
Hello.
Wow.
This place is packed.
Yeah.
A gnar...
Wait, what's this?
Rot scale.
Oh.
Today was like...
Oh my gosh.
I just decided recently that I won't eat rot scale anymore.
I guess my diet here would be corn.
Are they all drinking at the same time?
No.
One, two, three.
Oh.
That's not what I...
Okay.
What?
Hello.
They all got their own little lives.
It's actually so sweet.
It's so hard to concentrate with all that noise.
What noise?
Hello?
You'll need to speak up.
It's just down the road from Passwall.
It's where Wilmina created the gatekeeper.
Oh.
The gardens of flesh involved.
Oh, the voices in her head.
Really?
A gnarle are strange creatures.
Hit them with a fireball and they get stronger.
But they hate other elements even more.
Oh.
Passwall.
I don't know who built it.
It was here before any of us arrived.
It looks like other people lived here before.
Dreadwind's been selling what they left behind, so if you need something, talk to her.
She's in the wastrel's purse.
Wastrel's purse, I see.
Doesn't that noise bother anyone else?
Ma'am?
Do you know how to blink?
Yes, what is it?
Oh.
Apparently she does.
Let's go back to this guy's house.
The arrows, the arrows!
They must be finished.
Or maybe he's not here.
Oh.
We should go hunting.
Soon.
Wait.
Oh, and arrows?
The arrows are ready.
Here are some for you.
And I'll keep some.
Let's go?
Let's go kill the gatekeeper.
We might die.
But there's worse things.
True.
20 gatekeeper...
Okay.
Follow me.
Let's go!
Hell yeah!
Let me equip them.
Gatekeeper bone arrow.
Wah!
This is fancy.
Wait.
This is nice.
Hopefully 20 is enough.
20.
I can get him in half.
Wait.
Where am I?
What do I get out?
Oh.
Wait.
What's this?
A little vase.
Here we go!
Are you off to watch us kill the gatekeeper?
This is where we save.
Are you ready?
J Red?
I wanna loot those guys too.
Alright.
We need to get through the gates of madness.
Let's go kill the gatekeeper.
Kill the gatekeeper!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Kill the gatekeeper!
Wait.
I can get three times damage on him?
No I can't.
Maybe?
Yes I did.
Let's go.
Okay.
Kill the gatekeeper!
J Red.
It's time to kill the gatekeeper.
Why can't I run?
There we go.
Oh, just one more!
How many did I use?
Ow!
Let's go.
We did it!
We need to get through the gates of madness.
Oh.
Let's go kill the gatekeeper.
He's a little slow.
Let's go!
The gatekeeper is dead.
I shall retrieve the keys to the gates of madness from the gatekeeper's corpse.
The gatekeeper is slain.
Congratulations.
The honor of taking the keys from his corpse is yours.
Aw, Jared!
See you later.
Yeah.
Whoa!
Look at his face.
Where... where are the keys?
Uh...
Taking it all, baby.
I love Jared.
Oh!
This stuff is...
Pretty penny.
She did, in fact, use less than half.
Only eight shots.
Enough to kill any gatekeeper that moves.
We'll come back for all...
Wait!
Can I sell this to that lady?
Oh.
I have both the keys to mania and the keys to dementia.
I can get through either... or I can go through either doors...
Of the gates of madness.
I can hear the bones talking.
Oh my god!
So, you've managed to kill the gatekeeper.
Where did he come from?
Pity.
Well, you'll now be able to enter the realm proper.
You'll notice there are two doors.
Yes.
One leads to the lands of mania.
Yeah.
The other to dementia.
Enter through either one.
Yeah.
The lands are quite distinct, but both are Shayagorath's domain.
So I can...
You'll want to seek out Lord Shayagorath.
I believe he has plans for you.
Try not to disappoint him.
Okay.
Which one should I go in, you guys?
Explore both?
So I guess we'll go to both.
Mania.
The lands of mania are bright, vibrant, and full of color.
You'll find its inhabitants reflect the land itself.
If you wish to meet the residents of mania, you'll find them in the settlements of Hale and High Cross.
Take care though.
Mania sounds pretty.
If citizens and creatures of mania are colorful, they can often be quite deadly.
Okay.
I'm sure you can handle it though.
And then dementia.
This is...
Why dementia?
That's so sad.
The lands of dementia reflect the darker side of its residents.
It is easy to get lost among the tangle of roots growing out of the ground.
If you wish to meet dementia's citizens, seek them out in Deepwallow or Felmore.
I'm sure they'll welcome one such as you with open arms.
Oh, what do you mean by that?
Enlightening as always.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't realize he'd disappear.
Wait, I can keep talking to him.
Just kidding.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't ask him about everything.
Hold on.
I want to make sure...
I want to see if we can sell this stuff to the lady at the inn.
Cause if we can, I'll take it all and then just sell it right now, you know?
Take all the money she's got.
Does money mean anything here?
Ouch.
Why is this always shaking?
Excuse me.
I must have nodded off there.
Oh!
We can.
She just doesn't...
Yeah.
Okay.
Hold on.
So?
You're full of it.
That's a bit excessive.
No more.
That's pretty good.
Okay.
That was...
I think that was a perfect match, actually.
Oh.
Not great.
That's a bit excessive.
Yeah.
I get it.
Blah, blah.
Yes.
What have you say?
We did go up technically, I think.
You're a big fat liar.
Was that supposed...
Don't.
A phony.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Oh nay.
It was that supposed to be a...
No more.
Yeah.
Okay.
I get it.
62.
Oh, that's all we can do.
See you later.
Ah!
And I had my...
I had my thing in.
Wait.
So...
Our disposition is at 72.
This is good.
I'm so tired.
Let's go.
Maybe we can...
Maybe...
She'll be so sleepy.
We can add an extra zero.
Alright.
Let's...
Go grab all this stuff.
Because we're definitely gonna be over encumbered.
And then we'll go sell it.
And get hot...
High dollar dollar.
Let's take the most expensive stuff.
Actually.
Whoa!
He's a cheetah man!
Wait.
Oh.
Wow.
Okay.
I'm over encumbered.
I don't know if you guys can tell.
What's this little tail?
If I'm already over encumbered, what's a little bit more, right?
Beep, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Someone pointed out she only has 300 gold.
Yeah, but...
Um...
We'll try.
What if she's hiding some in her pockets?
I can't even imagine.
I'm like walking away like an old man.
Everything's stacked on my back.
And I'm like...
I'll be back.
Don't mind me.
Wait, but the guy wanted the gatekeeper dead.
Does he not want to go inside...
Dementia or...
Mayhem with me?
Death Stranding mode.
Truly, this is a stranding game.
I have the keys.
Yeah, but I can unlock it for him if he asks.
He just likes bones.
I can't even jump.
That's crazy.
This is weight training.
When everything comes off, I'm gonna be...
Rock Lee.
I kinda like her.
He is...
So innocent about the thing he loves.
Bones, you know?
Okay, here we go.
Who are ya?
Ma'am?
Wake up.
Oh, hello there.
I'm here to barter.
I've got many items.
Such as the steel hammer.
Wait.
No.
Haggle.
There we go.
What if like this?
60%.
She took it.
Nice.
Steel shield.
We're getting money.
Maybe I can go up a little.
Maybe 65.
Offer refused.
Dang it.
Okay.
62.
No!
Okay.
Back to 60.
Vivicore!
Thank you so much for the farm gift and thank you.
This cure us.
Oh.
Let's go.
I might be a genius.
I might be a genius, baby!
I think that was everything, though.
I think that was everything.
Look how much money we made back.
See you.
See ya!
That was way more than 300.
Yeah!
I think it's the max that they spend at one time.
So all I had to do was split it up.
Oh, oh.
Oh...
I thought he...
I thought he was break dancing.
Oh...
Yes?
I wonder if I should sell the rest of the stuff.
Will I be over-encumbered if I take all of this?
Oh, I'm not!
Even the skellies have gold.
I need more skellies for me to...
Did I search this guy?
Yeah.
This guy?
No.
Gold?
A brass pearl ring!
Okay.
Let's go sell this stuff.
There's also shields.
Were they on the ground?
Did I miss them?
I did!
Thank you!
I did.
Okay.
That one sword was enough to do me in.
Do I have any feather spells?
I'll be honest...
I don't know how to play this game.
I don't...
I think I'm just, like, anti-magic.
Because even when I play...
What?
Even when I play...
Like, I've been playing a lot of Fantasy Life, too.
And even in that game, I choose sword over everything else.
I don't know.
I think I just hate spells.
I just want to use my fists.
What if I did 61%?
Ma'am, we're friends, no?
Nice.
We have...
Guys, we started with 50 gold.
I think.
We started with a sub 100 gold at the beginning of this stream.
You're so real for this and so relatable.
Magic is too complicated.
Maybe I'm just stupid.
Bye.
Maybe I am just a dummy.
And I just want to brute force everything.
Maybe I'm just like...
I don't know.
I'm like...
Me, no magic.
Me, no reed.
Me...
He's ragdolling again.
He keeps looking like he's break dancing.
Hi.
Soon.
Yeah.
The gatekeeper's dead.
As soon as you get one of those doors unlocked, we can go in.
They're calling to me from in there.
Soon as you get those doors unlocked, I'm going in.
Okay.
Let's get those doors unlocked.
See you later.
For you, buddy.
J-Red!
J-Red the go.
Oh.
Oh, we're going into dementia.
Oops.
Maybe we can get the sad one out of the way.
I've entered the Shivering Isles.
I should seek out...
Sheogorath.
Hi.
Oh.
Bye.
Do you feel it?
Do you feel the dementia?
It doesn't look very much different than the last area we were in, to be honest.
What?
Who are you again?
Oh, wait.
We should go up this way.
It's a camp.
Oh.
Are the people here friends?
This is a summer camp, no?
They should be friends.
We're at the camp.
You didn't just pull out a knife, did you?
Oh, shoot.
He knows magic.
Oh, my God.
Wait!
You and your stupid child can die...
Oh.
He's gone?
Oh, just kidding.
I hear something.
What the hell is that?
Oh, my God.
My friend is getting attacked.
I'm so sorry.
I thought you were just not helping me.
Ew.
Where'd my friend go?
J-Red!
What are you doing over there?
Over here.
I'll take my stuff back.
I don't need anything else.
Wow.
Wait.
That's kind of...
Kind of...
Worth a lot of money.
I'm at camp.
Why do they call it camp if it's, like, evil?
You know?
It's a little misleading.
Oops.
Some fungus.
I didn't want that.
Yikes.
Whoa!
Oh!
Most camps in the base games are bandit camps.
That's so sad.
He looks...
He was wearing such, like, a pretty outfit, even.
So I was like, you know...
I don't know where my friend is.
We've lost J-Red.
For good, maybe.
Wait.
I really don't know where he is.
J-Red!
Can you hear me?
Are you lost?
Just...
Follow the sound of my voice!
We gotta go this way, anyway.
Oh!
Oh my god, he listened.
Where are you going?
You remember me, right?
What?
We should go hunting, soon.
See, he still wants to go hunting.
Okay.
See you later!
See you!
I'm nervous for him.
Okay, we know those things are nasty, icky, evil, gross.
I can hear them crawling a mile away.
He just needs some quality standing time.
I hope he doesn't forget why he came here, you know?
Oh!
I can't see anything!
Wait.
Maybe we should follow the road.
Um...
Do you think I can make it?
Oh, we'll be fine.
Oh.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Is that a friend, or...
No, probably not.
Oh, I see a skelly.
Wait, you think I can get him from here?
Ultimate sniper?
Oops.
Holy!
That other guy disappeared.
Disappeared.
Where'd he go?
Nice shot.
Thanks.
I lost the other guy, though.
Okay, maybe it's a good thing J-Red did not follow us.
We're in a really...
We're in...
Zaselm.
And that place, nobody wants to be here.
Where'd he go?
Where'd the big glowy guy go?
I'm more afraid of him than the skelly.
Hi.
Okay.
Um...
Where should...
I guess I can just drop down right here.
I'm still sneaking, though.
Whoa!
Oh, it's a zombie!
Maybe?
Whoa!
He's not gonna come back to life, is he?
The...
Mangled flesh.
Void essence.
That...
Had a pretty penny on it.
Okay.
Onwards!
Towards...
This...
City!
It...
Was a zombie.
Oh my gosh.
Game lagging.
We're okay.
Let's see a spitter.
He's a little stupid.
That was not a great shot, but it got the job done.
I think I should go...
The other way.
Oh!
People die when they are killed.
What the hell is that?
Is that a hunger?
It's a gnarle sapling.
Those are gnarles.
I don't like this place anymore.
I wanna get to the city.
Wait, where did die at?
Oh, here it is.
Amber.
Oh, it's got the gnarle bark!
Everything's gnarle.
My bad.
Press the wrong button.
There's a person in that water.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, it's so creepy.
Maybe...
I hear something.
J-Rod?
Oh, that's like a lizard.
I'm not so scared of that.
I just don't wanna get ambushed for something.
I'm trying to go around.
We'll just go around.
Lizard.
It's so hard.
As long as we stay on the edge.
I think we'll be okay.
What the?
Hey.
You were supposed to die in one hit.
Dementia is gross and creepy.
Mania is a lot more visually appealing.
But lizards are cute.
Yeah, this place sucks.
You know what?
It's better to get the bad one out of the way though first, no?
He's faster than I expected.
It doesn't look like a lizard.
It looks like a rat person.
Speaking of...
Holy cow.
Don't scream like that.
You freaked me out.
Oh.
My aim.
Okay.
What is this?
Is this anything here?
Anything special?
Oh, it's a hunger!
Get his tongue.
Oh, I see him.
Hunger's got your tongue.
Let's go.
Gosh, we're still so far from the city.
They're freaky, uh...
We gotta go this way.
Maybe running around here is a bit foolish, but...
Another camp!
Okay.
Careful!
Easy!
Camps are not...
Friendly.
Wait, there's a wall?
Guys, maybe I should've taken the road.
Nice!
Check the map.
You're so right.
The...
My tail!
As an Argonian, I like the dementia regions.
It's cold, wet, and miserable.
Just like home.
I think we could actually...
Wait, can we fast travel?
Maybe not.
We'll make it!
Am I gonna get possessed of...
Thoughts of sewer side?
On this...
On this area?
Okay, I think we can get up here.
Sewer slide, yeah.
It's also like...
Night time, right?
It should look better in the day, right?
Oh, that dog's got manja!
Ooh-hoo-hoo!
I put the...
I put him out of his misery, truly.
It's a skinned hound.
Wait, this is day time?
Wait, what time is it?
No, no, see?
It's 12 AM.
It is quite night.
Can we see...
The...
Wow!
Actually, what if I just stand here for like 12 hours?
Hello, VTuber.
Hi!
Oh...
Oh, see?
It's so much brighter.
We could see the falls there.
That's crazy.
If I go down this way, we could go around like this.
So this way, I think?
Yes.
Yeah, it's a little bit better.
On the road again.
I can't wait to be on the road again.
Oh...
Is that a hunger?
Wait, who sees me?
Who sees me?
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh, he's hungry!
Oh,
he's hungry!
I heard another one.
I don't think that's me splashing out of the water.
You say how hungry?
I think we know.
He came after me...
Very eagerly.
It's a bit of a roundabout way, but I think it works.
Just got your GamerSub stuff in the mail!
Love your content.
Glad to see you doing well.
Thank you, Shio!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
I saw a guy here.
I did, I did.
I spy with my Minto eyes.
A little man!
Ha-ha!
Blister Pod.
I like how there's a graveyard here.
Hey, so was this place normal before?
Why else would there be a graveyard?
Curious.
Is the madness setting in?
I don't feel any worse than normal.
I don't know if that's a good thing or not.
Sorry I'm sneak walking the whole time.
I just don't want to get...
Are we going the right way?
Yes.
Oh shoot.
Oh!
Where'd he go?
Uh-oh.
Maybe I should've...
Left him alone.
Maybe I...
Shouldn't have bothered.
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Okay, bye!
Uh...
Whoa!
Cal...
Calor...
Because...
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
Really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, where did this guy go?
He disappeared under the water and never returned!
I did not kill him!
I did not!
Ah!
Sorry!
Young Ballywog!
Stay away!
Alright, hold on.
I need to go...
This way, I think?
Oh, wait.
I took that.
It was worth nothing, but that's fine.
Wait, I need to go...
This way.
Yes!
Okay!
Slowest jump scare...
You
just didn't expect to see him standing there!
He was much bigger than I expected!
He was just taller than...
What I imagined!
See, there he is!
There's...
There's another guy.
He was...
Walking...
Really...
Really slow towards me.
Okay guys, we're almost there!
Just...
A hundred steps!
We are like so...
Stinking close.
Oh, house!
We keep going.
Hi, chat!
Aw!
Greeting each other!
It's like I'm in Florida!
Them swamps!
Every time I've played Oblivion and gone to the Shivering Isles, it's been weird.
Hours later, I haven't gotten used to it.
Kyrodil feels weird.
Oh, sorry.
Is it Kyrodil or Cyrodiil?
I keep forgetting.
Actually, I think I've been calling it Kyrodil this whole time, but it's Cyrodiil, isn't it?
Sorry.
I forgot.
Cyrodiil.
Yeah.
How come I...
He's hungry!
Hungry!
Oh, damn it.
Don't jump.
Oh my God!
Sorry.
Scared me.
Oh my God!
Back, fowl beast!
We're close to the graveyard.
We're on the right path?
Okay, yep.
Speeding through my bone arrows.
It's fine!
I have other arrows.
Wait, actually, are these better?
Or worse?
Oh wow, they're actually so much better.
Let's go back to my iron arrows.
We'll use these for an emergency.
Curcible.
I can't wait to like...
Go to the pretty...
Pretty place.
Another graveyard.
Why?
Oh!
What do you mean activate?
Wait, it's been a minute since I've saved.
Wait, what do you mean activate?
Here lies blaze set.
Faster than the wind.
Dumber than a stump.
Oh, okay.
Run Nesta lies here.
Covered in glory and dirt.
Helene the Deaf.
She never heard a coven!
Vilval Teleram was thrown into this hole.
You know who's gonna be here next?
Sexiest tootious.
Remember an endory.
One day she will rise and take her vengeance.
Okay.
It's the only one that sounded nice.
Awashi probably drowned or something silly.
Not that... Oh, a tree!
Nice.
I think we can get around this guy without Santas.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah, I'm just making sure.
What is this?
Oh, that's the graveyard we just saw.
Okay.
Nice shot, Mint.
Thank you!
Ooh!
We're so close.
We're... literally here.
We're outside the gates.
Eventually.
The gates... of somewhere.
Is this the path I should have taken?
Oh, there's a dog on the bridge!
That's not a dog.
I don't know what that is.
Wait, this place is actually beautiful.
What?
I love having dementia!
We made it!
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh, we made it finally.
Maggie?
I saw the Zaxxar, and I magged it too!
Oh, fribble!
This Mazkin must return to duty.
Galburst in it.
Blessings, citizen.
Yeah!
Hi!
Mad God's blessings.
The Mazkin guard Crucible in New Shayath.
We ensure the demented remain orderly and respectful of our Lord Shayath.
Miss Seducer.
Shayath Gareth is our Lord, ruler of the Shivering Isles.
It is by his whim that the Mazkin walk, and we serve our master to the death.
The Shivering Isles are a reflection of our Lord Shayath Gareth.
Divided, yet perfect.
Walk with our Lord.
Yes, ma'am.
Man.
Whoa.
Stinky hole.
What about you?
Who are you?
Tell the Dane!
Karnsky is Ralphing!
He reminds me of Glarther.
The quiet type.
Whoa, mysteries, you say?
Aeril's mysteries.
Do you prefer dementia or mania?
Well, I've only experienced dementia, so... You got a problem?
You got a problem?
This guy's got a problem with everybody, apparently.
Wait, don't come back!
You got a problem?
Firm arms?
A strong back?
Yes!
You'll do nicely.
It's a shame.
Time will ravage you, destroy you, wither you.
But there are alternatives.
Time need not slow you.
Tell me, have you ever considered placing yourself... on display?
On display?
Oh, yes.
You see, I am a student of chronomancy.
The magic of time alteration.
Using Magicka, I will slow your heart rate, your breathing, your movement, and your thoughts, until they may as well not be functioning at all.
And?
You will be perfectly preserved.
Taken out of time.
Beautiful forever.
I will display you with the rest in my collection.
Oh.
Wait, I can't say yes?
Uh, no thank you.
Oh.
What a pity.
Well then, what is it that I can do for you?
And be quick about it.
Every second that passes brings us closer to our graves.
Oh my god.
You may have experienced mania, but unfortunately, you have dementia.
Woo!
Recharge weapon purchase... Oh wait, that's...
Please, come back soon.
Thank you.
No telling what oddities I may have for you next time.
No, please!
Let me see your collection, mister!
Is this a part of your collection?
Wow.
What?
What a hunk.
You got a problem?
Well, hello there.
It's good to see such a well-equipped individual as yourself around these parts.
Dang, everybody's so into me.
Carrying all that gear will do that to you.
I'd be glad to shoulder some of the burden.
Relieve you of that expensive stuff.
Or is there something else I can take from you?
I mean, help you with.
Is this guy gonna...
pickpocket me?
But also, he's so like, he's so standoffish.
And then as soon as he talks with me, he's like...
Excuse me, I have important things to do.
He's like, oh madame, your stuff, your...
your things look so heavy.
Ma'am, may I please hold them for you?
Greetings.
Apologies, citizen.
But I must return to my post.
Goodbye.
Yes?
Glu...
Rolo...
Roles?
Your lips to his ears.
Not the lickpocket!
Did I say that on accident?
No, pickpocket!
I hear that Eril is fed up with Brythar's antics.
He really wants something done about it.
So kill Brythar.
Eril has a big problem with Brythar.
I don't know exactly what the problem is, but it's safe to say, Eril is making a huge fuss over...
There's...
Yeah.
Wait, does he want me to kill him?
Rrythar!
I'm good at that.
Okay, let's go to the red arrow.
Here we go.
Psst!
Over here!
I need to talk to you.
It's important!
Yes?
Over here!
I need to talk to you.
It's important!
Hey you!
I've got to ask you something.
Something important!
Shhh!
Just come over here!
Psst!
Over here!
I need to talk to you.
It's important!
Psst!
Over here!
I need to talk to you.
It's important!
Hey you!
Here!
You!
Come over here!
Psst!
Over here!
I need it.
I have a proposition for you.
Less not to talk about it here.
Meet me at the sewer grate, northeast of the Shergorath statue.
Oh no.
Come after dark.
Come alone.
This is giving me Glarther vibes for real!
For the dead gifted thank you!
Oh, hello.
How may I serve?
Sorry.
Can I jump up here?
Okay, hold on.
You didn't see that.
What we're gonna do is we're gonna go to the sewer.
I've got fresh sticks!
Guaranteed no leaves!
And we're gonna wait.
We're gonna wait until...
It was probably the sewer that I saw before, maybe.
Actually, I'm not sure.
A tap house.
What does that mean?
Like, uh...
Remember I said there was a stinky hole?
It's probably that, I imagine.
I didn't expect to mean to stream while I was at work.
Glad you're feeling better.
Thank you!
Have a good time at work!
Good luck!
Oh, what's this?
Oops.
Potion of Feather!
Wait, didn't someone mention this earlier?
Oh, the bird left it.
Oh.
Maybe not.
I saw the zaxer, and I'm at it too!
Oh, fribble!
Blessings of the mad gods.
What's happening?
Walk without fear.
Gal bursting it.
Who's hitting stuff?
Okay, hold on.
I'm getting down.
We're doing it.
I'm not breaking any bones.
Let's go.
Or maybe it's this one.
Hmm.
I think it was your feet.
No!
No way!
Hold on, I'll wait here.
It's three, so let's wait...
What, like seven hours?
That's nine.
We'll find him.
Is this him?
This is not our guy.
Maybe this is not the area.
Or wait, is this it?
Was I right the first time?
Oh my gosh, I was!
Hot dog!
Hey, you!
Come over here.
I need to talk to you.
It's important.
Won't someone end me?
Take my life.
Please.
Here is no!
I'm glad you came.
So, are you interested in earning some loot?
Yes.
Great.
There's a...
A simple task.
Yes.
A simple task that you must perform.
Okay.
What's the task?
This...
Life...
It's...
Well, it's too painful.
Everywhere I look, I see death, dying, and decay.
When I dream, I see a world without sunshine.
I'm constantly on the verge of retching up, or falling asleep, or screaming at someone who doesn't deserve it.
I'm just so fed up with it all.
Oh!
I don't think he's having just a bad day!
Hey!
Oh!
Itina!
We're right next to this...
S...
Sewer slides!
I kinda wanna see the third answer just because it's so horrible.
It is what E-Tina would say.
Have you seen those miserable souls on the hill of suicides?
Do you think that that kind of existence is any better than this?
No, you must kill me.
How do you want to die?
I don't necessarily want to see it coming.
And I want to die here in the city so all these people finally believe me.
I wish they were nicer.
You probably want to do it without spectators, though, so you don't get in trouble.
Best to make it look like an accident.
But remember, I don't want to see it coming.
Take me unaware.
How?
It should look like an accident.
Well, that's up to you, I suppose.
I'm going to go about my daily life, such as it is.
You gotta looney tunes it.
As if nothing has changed.
I'm gonna put an anvil on his head.
Make a move when you wish.
But please, do it soon.
Oh, and about this reward?
Oh, that.
When you kill me, take the key to my house.
Nothing really worth taking except what's locked up in the jewelry box.
You can have that.
Okay.
I'm going to pretend everything is normal.
Make your move as soon as you can.
But let me get away first so I don't know it's coming.
Often with old age.
Oh.
Not like this.
I didn't do anything, guard.
Uh...
An accident.
Please!
No!
Not yet!
You're making it really obvious!
Please!
No!
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Um...
Please, no!
This is a wild first side quest.
Okay.
Ask that I kill him.
How could I make it an accident?
How do I make it an accident?
Hmm...
Do I like pick this up?
I don't think an arrow in his head...
It looks like an accident.
Poison food.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe I like...
Where'd he go?
Maybe I sneak some poison food into his...
Into his pocket.
Let's assuming he'll eat it.
I could try and shoot him.
I was thinking about that apple too.
Wait.
Save?
Sorry, I forgot how to quick save you guys.
You've trained for this.
Think of all the Barneys you accidentally killed.
It's so me!
This is our guy, no?
Wait.
What if this is not our guy?
I think it's him.
Uh...
How do I push?
Come on, man.
I'm trying to make it easy for you.
Sometimes I come up here to think.
Everything looks so small from up here.
Makes me feel better, you know?
Like I'm not so small myself.
But that feeling only lasts a little while.
Then I start thinking about how miserable everything is, and then all I want to do is step off the ledge.
I can't just jump.
Don't want to end up on the hill.
But I hope that someday maybe a big gust of wind will come and push me off so I can end it all.
Today's your lucky day.
What?
Someone really ought to put up a railing.
That happens all the time.
Curious...
Cluedamnus is dead.
Just as he wanted.
I can now get my reward from his house.
The key should be on his core.
Someone really ought to put up a railing.
That happens all the time.
Oh, there he is!
Oh, face first in the goo!
I have...
...Heras' house key.
I should go claim my reward from his jewelry box.
I took a little extra too, sorry.
Where's his house?
Just as he wanted.
He said...
Things found upper floor.
Things found.
Hello, where's your home?
Oh!
Oh, oh!
Wait, oh!
I didn't see it marked.
This isn't it, right?
Is this
it?
No.
Timeless last words.
What?
He said, don't make it obvious.
It was...
Oh.
He had interesting...
Whoa.
He had interesting decor taste.
Oh.
Whoa.
I have a witness.
She didn't even care.
Oh, his place is so...
So small.
Oh!
Shut up!
It's a ring of happiness?
I've claimed your eye reward.
Wait, what does it say?
Wait, let's put on a ring?
Why wasn't he wearing it?
Uh...
Oh, here.
Uh, here.
I've wanted to die for quite some time.
Things just aren't going right.
Never have gone right, really.
No one seems to care either.
Nor even notice I exist.
Not that I'd have much to say even if someone had wanted to be my friend.
I'd make a lousy friend anyway.
I'm probably even boring the person reading this.
I'm certainly boring myself.
Not that anyone will ever find this note.
Oh, but if they do...
Did Eeyore write this right?
If they do, it means that I've been granted my greatest wish.
To be released from this mortal coil.
This isn't a sewer side note.
No.
That would mean I've taken my own life and we all know what that means.
Who wants that kind of existence?
To be reborn on a hill every day.
Reset as if nothing ever happened.
That's even worse than the life I'm living.
Life I've lived.
Yes, yes, yes.
I sure...
I'm sure I'm happy now.
The dead me.
The me writing this note isn't happy at all.
Never have been happy really.
Anyway, the purpose of this note is to say to the man or woman who has killed me.
Thank you.
All I really have is this queer little ring.
A wizard gave it to me once.
Said I reminded him of his dead son.
I guess I resemble his dead son even more now.
He never even wore it.
Wait.
Maybe he did.
Anyway, he said it would make me happy.
Lift the weight of the world off my shoulders or some such thing.
Come to think of it, it's the only time anyone has ever given me anything.
Personally, I think this...
Think the thing is worthless.
Just like me.
I tried it for a while.
The happiness ring.
But eventually I couldn't wear it anymore.
It made me feel odd.
Not myself.
I didn't like feeling that way, so I locked it away.
He didn't like being happy?
He wasn't used to happiness?
It's pretty enough though.
It might fetch a few gold coins at the merchant.
Sorry not to leave much more behind.
But my life never really amounted to much anyway, did it?
Yours truly...
Yours very truly.
Here was Clutimus Deceased.
I had fun once, it was awful.
Yeah, truly.
What was he reading?
The Liturgy of Affliction.
Ripperoni.
So sad.
Oh yeah, we were gonna go see that guy, the king or whatever.
Hello.
Yes?
You okay?
You got a tummy ache?
You got some skooma, eh?
Run, buddy!
Not the skooma!
To share!
Come on!
Pass the skooma already!
No!
No skooma!
Wait, do I still have skooma?
All right.
It's about time.
Give it me already.
Get your own skooma.
Don't be so cruel!
I hope you die a horrible death!
Next time, bring some skooma with you.
Okay, ma'am.
Oh.
She got the skooma shakes.
No skooma!
No more!
Okay.
I think I remember.
It was like around over here.
This place is...
Yeah.
Up here.
Her voice changed so much.
I hope you die a horrible death!
If you don't break the skooma!
You are!
Whoa!
Oh!
Hairy tree!
Whoa!
Oh my gosh!
Hi!
Sorry!
It's beautiful!
Are you a seducer too?
Speak citizen!
No, you're a golden saint guard.
Speak quickly!
Yeah, you are hot though.
Sheogorath rules the Shivering Isles.
We, the Oriole, are his favorite soldiers.
The most perfect expression of his might.
Damn.
Go.
Yes, ma'am.
It's a terrific JPEG.
With the sky?
Yeah, I thought so too.
Is this him?
Activate.
How do I activate these busts?
Um, hold on.
I'm gonna go back to...
Oh, shoot.
I'm gonna go back to, uh...
This.
Oh, up here.
How may I serve?
Me when I'm a maid.
Oh wait.
That's every day.
How may I serve?
You can't on stream, it's TOS.
What are you asking for?
What?
There's our man!
The slow clap.
Is that for me?
Wait!
You have dementia, and you have the mania.
Hello!
Well, look who's here!
You!
Hey!
How about that?
Yeah!
I sing Lord of the Rings while...
20 shots...
in.
Oh.
Uh...
Drink some water, Sharko!
A new arrival!
New arrival!
I'm so happy, I could just...
Eat a horse!
...tear out your intestines, and strangle you with them!
I suppose an introduction is in order.
I'm Sheogorath, Prince of Madness!
And...
Other things.
I'm not talking about them.
You've probably figured that out by now.
Let's hope so.
Or we're in real trouble.
And...
Out come the intestines!
Oh.
And I...
Skip rope with them!
He's really into my intestines.
But perhaps...
Now's not the time.
And you've made it this far.
Farther than anyone else.
Well done!
Take him out to dinner first.
Take this trinket of mine.
Perhaps it will serve you well.
Or look...
Lovely on your corpse.
Ooh!
What do you want?
I got a charity of madness?
Is that what it said?
I've been waiting for you!
For someone like you.
He's flirting with me.
For someone other than you, for some time.
Oh, did he just lose his hand?
I'm the champion!
And you've...
Got the job!
Trying to save the realm!
Rescue the damsel!
Slay the beast!
Or die trying.
Your help is required.
A change is coming!
Everything changes!
Even Daedric Princes.
Especially Daedric Princes.
Okay.
Changes?
Daedra are the embodiment of change.
Change and permanency.
I'm no different.
Except in the ways that I am.
A Grey March is coming!
And you're going to stop it.
Grey March.
The details aren't important.
At least, not right now.
Okay.
Eternity is on a rather tight deadline.
We'll get back to that later.
What now?
Now, you run an errand for me.
An important one.
Of course.
Anything I tell you to do...
Is important.
My realm.
My rules.
You're going to Zedillion.
One of my favorite spots in the Isles.
It's a little place I used to take care of...
Did I go there?
Unwanted visitors.
And some are more unwanted than others.
Did I accidentally find that place?
Why Zedillion?
The gatekeeper takes care of most of the unwanted.
But he's dead.
We'll have to remedy that soon as well.
Anyway.
There are those that have other ways into my realm.
And they're on the move.
We don't want them here.
Trust me.
How did you expect me to get them?
So, you're going to get Zedillion up and running.
You know.
Here's a little book to tell you how.
And the attenuator of judgment.
You'll need that too.
Oh, oh.
Of course.
You can always get more details from Haskell.
He's a detail-oriented type of person.
A big help.
And a snappy dresser.
Now, get going.
Before I change my mind.
Or my mind changes me.
Reached a spirit rank in the Court of Madness.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Ha?
You can go now.
Run along.
Scoot.
Hi, Haskell.
Always a pleasure.
Yeah, I know.
He reminds me of some... someone.
I can't.
Like some TV...
Or some movie character.
I can't...
I can't place it.
Shoo.
Go.
Be gone.
Things to do.
Boop.
Always a pleasure.
Okay.
What about your bust?
What's this?
The door is sealed.
Aww.
What's this?
Activate.
Nothing activates here.
Everything is broken.
In the original game...
Shiel Garroth...
Was the only NPC with a proper beard.
Wow...
Etina must feel so cool...
Like...
Being...
Below this, you know?
Okay.
One thing I do want to do...
Is...
Can we go back here?
Wait, no.
We found...
Wait.
Where are we going?
We found...
I think we found the wrong place.
But I want to go see the other place too.
So let's go to the Gates of Madness...
Again.
And we're gonna leave...
Dementia World.
And we're gonna go instead to...
Uh...
Madness.
Mania World.
Woohoo!
Mania World sounds like a really fun...
Um...
A really fun theme park, actually.
You can go to Mania from the Capitol?
Oh...
Oops.
I went the long way.
You can just head north of the city.
Oops.
I didn't know.
Wait.
It's okay though.
We're here.
There we go.
Do you think...
Jared's okay?
Do you think that guy is alright?
Do you think he's...
Around?
Still?
A thousand...
Okay, but this place might not be as evil.
Maybe.
What the?
Are you kidding me?
If we went to the left...
Is he still here?
JJ!
He's gone.
No way.
So if we went to the right...
Oh...
And if we went to the left...
No.
What?
JJ!
We should go hunting...
Soon.
He's alright!
The gatekeeper's dead.
He won't stop us from coming and going now.
Yeah.
If you have to fight a flesh Atronach, a good shock spell is the way to go.
See you!
He hasn't even made it...
Even a little...
Far.
Okay, so we go this way.
What time?
Oh, you cannot wait when enemies are...
Wait, where?
I just wanted to see what time it was.
What do you mean there's enemies?
Oh.
You cannot wait when enemies...
Where?
Maybe we should just go back to the palace room.
The time is on the map?
Oh.
It's 7am.
Hmm.
Curious.
This place is pretty though.
It's real cute.
Halala!
This way?
Which way?
Oh my gosh.
It is a long...
Long...
Road.
We're gonna go to here.
I wanna go to the other city.
Oh wait.
Would I...
I wonder if...
Will I run into her?
How do I get out of here?
Blessings, citizen.
I'm lost!
How do I get out of your castle?
Um...
North?
Up here?
Speak quickly, mortal.
I'm lost!
Here's the exit.
I don't know where it is!
I've got his bust and that's about it!
Wait, can I jump out from here?
No.
I found it!
Oh my gosh!
We made it!
Okay.
Is this a different town now?
Hello!
Ungor?
I don't belong here!
I'm not crazy!
Not like the rest of them!
They watch me, you know, waiting for me to go crazy!
This guy is just Glarthor.
But I won't...
Nope!
I think Glarthor belongs here.
Umag Grabonk, at the missing pauldron, is collecting that amber you find in the root tunnels.
Okay.
Bye.
We have one mission.
Greetings!
Oh.
I'm not like them.
Are you?
Are you one of them?
Cease your prattling.
Take care!
You good?
Hello.
Don't mind me.
I'm a little tired.
Can't sleep at home, you know.
The walls, they aren't safe.
I also walk like that when I'm tired.
The walls aren't safe.
Don't you know?
You don't, do you?
Well, it's lucky you met me.
Here, you've been walking around as if nothing could happen.
Mm-hmm.
Oh my gosh.
Short, hairy bloke.
Thank you so much for talking after.
Thank you!
Why don't you just sleep outside?
Well, there's an idea.
Why didn't I think of that?
But where would I sleep?
I need some place to sleep.
Anywhere in the world is your oyster.
I've seen some people sleeping out on the street, but they huddle too close to the walls.
I need some place safe.
I can't just sleep anywhere.
There are walls and statues and all sorts of things that can fall on me.
Can't have that.
Oh, he's afraid of the wall falling on him.
But if you find me a good place to sleep, a safe place outside, I'll reward you.
Okay.
Sleep outside.
Oh, don't tease me.
It's serious.
I could die.
We all could die.
Please, help find a safe spot outside to sleep where the walls won't come crashing down.
Okay.
Got any remarks?
Luma Grabonk at the missing pauldron is collecting that amber you find.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye.
Is he gonna go crawling away?
Even this guy's staring at him like, what the...
I'm in bliss.
This place is so pretty though.
What?
What is this?
The missing pauldron.
This place is so pretty.
He's training his quads, books of bliss.
Yes.
Oh.
Hello.
Who are you?
Yes.
Hi.
Sleep outside.
Wait, do you also want to sleep outside?
Yes, I have an idea for you.
But first, sweet roll for Fimian.
Sweet roll for Fimian.
Idea for you.
Sweet roll!
I don't have a sweet roll for you.
No sweet roll for Fimian.
No answer to problem.
Hmph.
Sweet roll!
See you later.
Bye.
Wow.
Sweet roll!
I also heard Fimian.
Where is she?
She's in here, right?
We're in the right place?
We will find her.
My sweet.
Sweet roll!
No, it's too close to the walls.
Speak quickly, mortal.
The choosy beggar.
Rendell's house.
This is a village near.
The J in the word Jester written on the map.
Oh my gosh.
Palm putt.
Thank you.
Ah!
Okay.
We just gotta go through bliss.
Thank you!
Let's go find her.
I was gonna say...
I remember from the screenshot...
Or not sorry.
Hi.
I remember it looked a little more...
Like...
A little less city.
Sweet roll!
Hi.
You look not...
Wait.
Have you caught my act yet?
I'm fatal, the juggler.
I'm sure you've heard of me.
I haven't.
Oh, who am I kidding?
Oh.
More likely you came to scoff at the worst juggler in the world.
I didn't say...
Those are your words.
Oh.
Heretics are misguided worshippers of Arden Sue.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Hi.
I...
I'm sure you're a great juggler, man.
I see something over there.
Are there spiders...
Oh my god!
He's just standing there!
Okay, so this area has the same type of monsters.
Got it.
Haha!
How many steps?
Oh, not so bad.
This place is quite orange, isn't it?
Wow.
Good morning.
Okay.
It does kind of wind a bit.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
What is this?
Uh-oh.
I sneak in case...
There's some...
Manner of...
Whoa!
Oh my god.
He's still standing there.
I like seeing the city from outside and stuff.
Okay.
I thought this might be a guy who's...
You know, at the camp, you know.
I feel like I'm in the jungles of Russia.
Can I shoot him?
Of course I could.
Not gonna waste my time with him though.
He would chase me all the way to the village.
These trees are quite quirky.
Wow.
Shoot.
No!
Showing your face was the last mistake...
Oh my god.
No, why you...
No!
No, please!
Oh my gosh.
Please die.
No, I...
I am of you, yeah.
Let's get this over with.
Take that!
I didn't think he'd be so beefy!
Oh my god, he keeps healing.
Holy cow!
Give me all my stuff back.
I didn't think he was gonna go so hard on me.
My arrow.
Yuck.
Yuck city.
Oh, I...
Yeah, I was so panicked.
I forgot that I was in third person, if you want.
Or rather, like, you know, I forgot to switch to first person.
I see something down there.
Is that perhaps...
A little...
Okay, we'll just keep going on the path.
Purple.
On the road again.
I can't wait to be on the road again.
I'll get back into...
Here we go.
Oh shoot.
There we go.
Easy.
No worries here.
This guy is ugly.
Hello, Minto.
Hope you're good.
I'm great, Jim.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for 15 months.
Thank you!
Welcome back.
Alright.
What's up there though, you know?
There's so much to explore.
Gosh, I love exploring in games.
It's like my favorite thing to do in Minecraft, you know?
Is just...
Explore.
And look.
And see.
What is...
Oh, it's a big ol' body.
My athletics has increased...
Oh!
Tina, please!
What's this?
Aster Bloom Core.
Will these make me crazy?
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
I can probably see my house from here.
I thought this would be a landmark.
But I guess not.
Nasty!
So cool.
I won't kill the dog.
We're not going over there.
Wait.
I will shoot.
The crab though.
Oh.
He moved slower then.
I'm bad.
I don't think it reaches.
I played this game in middle school.
I fast traveled everywhere to beat the game.
Now I take my time and explore each part.
So much fun.
Yeah!
I mean, obviously it's nice to like, just get through it.
Oh my gosh.
You guys scared me.
Speak quickly, mortal.
Hello.
Is that a tree, ma'am?
Those things are weak.
Okay.
He's fine.
Don't, don't leave yet.
No, I didn't want your bark.
I think, I think maybe down there.
I think we can probably actually just go down.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding me right now?
No, please.
Oh,
please.
Oh my gosh.
Stop healing.
Stop.
Oh, I got him.
You bastard.
What did you think a bandit camp was?
I saw frenzied camp.
Worm head.
Name of the village.
I thought we were here.
Go, Etina, go.
Just run for it.
This is where we belong.
Here.
Do I spy with my minky eyes?
A lady?
Yes, what is it?
Yes.
Ah, a stranger in town.
But as I always say, a stranger is just a friend I haven't met yet.
Hey, friend, do you think you could help me out?
Yeah.
I'm caught a bit short at the moment.
Anything at all would be much appreciated.
Yes, yes.
Get lost.
I'll say have a coin.
There you go.
Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
If you want to get close to the heretics, try putting on their robes.
Wait, does that work?
I thought it would maybe work.
Bye.
Are you gonna keep running?
Oh.
Do you have any shoes?
No.
Merely offered me some shoes if I ran an errand for her research.
I just ran instead.
Say, do you have any shoes?
No, no shoes.
But how about a bath?
You really should take a bath.
You shouldn't run any errands for Merely until you take a bath.
Oh, these holes in my shoes are killing me.
Wait, is that a bad person?
Well, gotta run.
You have those shoes.
Hi.
There she goes.
Wait, that person's gone.
Oh, are they a heretic?
I can't tell.
Maybe not, because they don't have the hood on.
I don't have time to talk.
My work cannot wait.
What are you doing?
You're new here, so I'll try to be patient with you.
I am compiling a taxonomy of every living thing in the Shivering Isles, the weather, changes in the moon and stars, and their interrelationships.
Wow.
I must not be interrupted.
My work requires the highest degree of concentration.
How do I get her to say the line?
I hope I won't have to repeat myself.
Fascinating.
Tell me more.
I have no time for idle chatter with dilettantes.
When I'm finished with the Encyclopedia Shaothia, you may study it to your heart's content.
You got any shoes?
Bye.
What?
Hey, got any apples or carrots?
Anything at all crunchy and yummy to eat?
Suddenly, suddenly, the camera angle feels so intimate.
Like, I feel so close to her.
Get lost!
What?
What did you say?
Neneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneeneene
I'm crying, I'm so happy!
Oh my god!
Wait, I wanna go inside her house.
She won't notice.
We did it!
My reason for playing Oblivion was just for that!
After all this time... Finally!
I heard it with my own ears and my own... With... With...
With E-Tina on my side!
That's a screaming maw.
Wait, I can sleep in her bed.
You think she'll mind?
Aww...
No!
She's got a nice little balcony...
With a great view!
Wow!
Miss runs in circles!
Oops!
Ouch, sorry.
Hey, got any apples or carrots?
Anything at all crunchy and yummy to eat?
We did it!
Get lost!
What?
What did you say?
I my feet.
Me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me!
Me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me!
Hey, got any apples or carrots?
Anything at all crunchy and yummy to eat?
What is this gorgeous angle?
Oh my gosh, this is cinematic!
What the hell is this?
This is beautiful.
She wants something crunchy to eat.
Wow.
And the way she's, like, looking at us.
This is crazy.
It looks maxing.
Hold on, I need a screenshot.
Wait, how do you screenshot on... with Steam again?
I don't remember.
Yeah, is this a dating sim?
F-12.
Wait, hold on.
Let's get her to, like, kind of...
There we go.
And... Nope.
Dang it, I missed it.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, here we go.
Yes, Queen!
Yes!
Maybe the real dead Tootius was the Nene on the way.
Dang.
Get lost!
What?
What did you say?
I'm so happy!
Oh my god.
She's judging me, watching me.
Is that him right there?
Why is he blended?
She's got...
Whoa!
He's invisible.
Oh, he's diseased, not deceased.
Did you see that?
Did you check that out?
Yes, what is it?
Nothing.
Guys, I actually, though, have to use the little ghostie's room.
So, give me a moment...
Wait, why is it...
Why is the lock hard?
Why?
I gotta use the little ghostie's room.
Get through you!
Thank you so much for the 5.
I'll be right back.
I'll just let you chill with her for now.
Biori.
Hey, got any apples or carrots?
Anything at all crunchy and yummy to eat?
Hold on, I'm gonna go get more water, too.
I'm gonna get more water.
Wait, what happened?
Did she come up to me?
You lost.
Wh-what did you say?
Okay.
So sorry about that.
I, I, feel so satisfied with that.
I'm not gonna lie, that, ouch, I kind of want to just, Just... I kinda wanna just... Welcome back, thank you!
Kinda wanna just... Um... Not end it, obviously, but I wanna... I wanna go kill those guys.
Fulfill Glarthur, our first ever big quest.
I say big.
Our quest that has taken us so long.
And call it.
Where is she?
I saw you.
My queen!
Runs in circles!
Tell her sorry once, please.
Okay.
What?
My feet hurt so bad.
I could sure use a new pair of shoes.
Can you help me out?
Please?
How does she talk like that?
My feet hurt so bad.
How do you talk like that?
My... My... Feet hurt so bad.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
All right.
Can I travel?
Okay, so we're gonna have to go to the to the door to Cyrodiil?
All the way back...
Why am I- why am I- why do I look like this?
Why am I glowing?
I'm
fine, I'm fine!
What's wrong?
Oh, see?
Is it because of my buff?
Is it because I'm buffed?
The ring I'm wearing, maybe?
I've got like this...
Oh!
Whoa!
Ichida!
Oh, okay, you're fine.
Um...
Whoa!
Creepy!
What's down here, anyway?
Oh, just the water.
Whoa!
Before you go, it's my birthday!
Oh!
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday, Hitman!
No, no, we still got a little bit more work to do.
Still have a little bit more to do.
It was in Skingrad.
But let me go back to my quest.
We'll do it.
Go back to Paranoia.
Yes.
We will...
We will take care of this.
I won't feel satisfied if we don't...
Unless we do, you know?
Hurry up!
Glarthor!
So hot!
It's 6am!
And then Tudius is over here, right?
What is it?
Uh...
Over this way?
This way?
What is it?
Oh, excuse me.
I'm searching for, uh...
Mr. Sextius?
Tudius Sextius?
Oh, I can get rid of...
Oh, wait!
Oh, no!
My other marker was from...
Was...
From...
Here!
Oh, can I get rid of it?
Remove it.
There we go.
Okay, phew!
Tudius!
Uh...
Here!
Why does it say he's right here, but he's not?
Maybe he's upstairs.
Okay.
No way Minto is awake at 6am on a regular basis.
Ay, ay, ay!
Gosh, dang it.
Do I still have that, like...
Oh.
I don't know what I just...
What I just cast upon myself.
He doesn't know.
Equip my good arrows.
Oh, true.
True, true, true.
Gatekeeper.
Hey!
Don't look this way!
Get boned, Mr. Sextius.
Shoot.
Oh, no.
I have killed everyone on Glarthur's list!
Oh, when I have.
Okay, I was about to say.
Um, no I didn't.
Ah!
Stop!
You violated the law!
Pay the court a fine or serve your sentence.
Your stolen goods are now forfeit.
My bounty is...
1,000?
I could just go to jail.
Hmm...
A, what?
Resist?
Why?
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha...
Pay half to the Thieves Guild.
I guess that's true.
He's like...
He's like, very patiently waiting for us to make a decision.
Resist arrest, do it!
Let me... let me res... let me... let me...
Uh, what's the word?
I'll... I'll try again, I'll reload.
Loud!
Redoo!
Don't pay with your blood.
Oh.
No!
What are you doing?
Oh, he knows I'm here now.
Do you have more gatekeeper arrows?
Yeah.
That's what I used.
Paying your fine to resist arrest.
My turn.
Okay, hold on.
What we couldn't do before was the poison...
...was the poison apples because...
...they...
...they don't... they don't eat it.
So...
...what if I...
...or do I have anything?
Here, poison.
Poison for our arrows, yeah.
Uh...
Um...
I have...
...aero of fatigue.
Love the thumbnail, it's so cute.
Thanks!
Hmm...
Oblivion?
You can make NPCs...
...mad enough by intentionally failing the talking.
They attack you first.
Then you can kill them as a means of self-defense.
What?
No way!
Really?
Only it works on some NPCs, not all.
Should we try?
Hey, why not try at least?
Oh...
I did not mean to do that.
I don't know what I'm even...
I'm casting, like, healing on myself or something.
Hello!
Yeah, worth a shot, no?
Because there's, like, no way we're gonna one-shot this guy.
I won't fight you.
My life is...
What a dumb joke.
Alright, now we know.
It's really...
Oh gosh, okay.
It's really hard to, like...
...fail this, you know what I mean?
Such adventures.
How I envy you.
I want to...
I want to do it right.
Hate me!
I can't argue with...
Don't try to manipulate...
What a dumb joke.
That's amazing.
Not now.
You think that's funny?
Oh, shoot.
Dang it.
That's amazing.
You've got a point.
I got back to 20!
What do you mean I have a point?
Oh my gosh.
I'm just, like, so popular.
My personality is too good.
What?
That's just not funny.
Oh, wait.
Also, if I just sit here, it also goes down, right?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yup.
Yeah.
I have to do it eventually, though.
I salute you.
Most of you...
Don't talk such rot.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Trying to figure out...
Yeah, he hates us.
Actually, can I just leave?
Oh, shoot.
I can't.
Do good ones wait, then bad ones.
Yeah.
Trying to figure out what I want to do.
It's so much more difficult doing the opposite.
Sorry, I don't get it.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Can it get into the negative?
We'll let it go down to zero and then see if it goes into the negative.
All right, Toadius Sextius.
You don't...
Oh, only zero?
Oh, see, here I was thinking that I could go into the negative.
Oh, okay.
And...
Zero!
Don't try to manipulate me.
Are you serious?
Oh.
Uh...
Just leave!
Dang.
He has too much...
He's too...
What's the word?
Civilized.
He's too civilized.
What do you bother me?
Go away.
I'm waiting.
Say what you're going to say.
Okay.
I won't fight you.
I salute you.
Most impressive.
Not the fighting type.
Yeah.
That's just stupid.
Nineteen.
Eighteen.
What was I at?
Seventeen.
I missed it.
Why do you want him to hate you?
Because maybe if he hates us, he might attack us.
And then I can kill him in self-defense.
Uh...
Thirteen!
Twelve!
None none none man!
Uuuef!
No!
Okay.
Not now...
Not later!
Not ever.
I'm not impressed.
He hates me.
Just leave!
Attack me!
Make it quick.
You know you want to.
They say there are a bunch of people holed up in Summit Mist Manor.
Locked in.
Some kind of weird party or something.
A sex party?
Stop talking.
Enough.
I'm looking through your things.
I'm looking through your stuff.
I don't know, guys.
Hey, come on now.
There's no need to get fired.
I give up.
Don't give up.
Don't leave.
I need to get you.
Shoot.
No, no.
Please.
Shoot.
I got him.
Stop!
You violated the law.
Pay the court a fine or serve your sentence.
Your stolen goods are now forfeit.
You have the high ground if you don't.
Then pay with your blood.
Oh.
Oh, God.
I'm innocent.
City.
Okay.
Now we go back.
Run, run, run.
Now we go here.
You cannot fast travel with enemies nearby.
Oh, shoot.
How far do I need to get?
Oh my gosh, my legs.
A lark.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
He's not close.
What?
There's still enemies nearby?
Is he always there?
Okay, surely... That's a dog.
Shoot.
Oh, dang it.
Come on.
You're not the enemy.
I need it.
Please.
Dog.
Run.
I hear a horse.
The good arrows.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
My good arrows.
Guys, will I ever be free?
This was a bad idea, huh?
Why didn't I listen to you guys?
Guys, I'm free.
For now.
No, not the stables.
Yes, the district.
Okay.
All I need to do is pay off my fine, right?
Stop right there, criminal scum.
Nobody breaks the law on my watch.
I'm confiscating your stolen goods.
Now pay your fine, or it's off to jail.
I think I just have to pay the gold, you guys.
I think I have, I have, what?
1400?
I just got paid.
We'll make the money back from Glarthur.
I don't think I had any stolen goods, though.
You'll never truly be free because you love hijinks too much.
Guilty.
Have you tried killing him with a dagger yet?
Yup.
I've tried so many things to try and kill these guys.
I have.
I sold all my stolen goods, though.
Yeah, okay.
That's too bad.
I was hoping you'd resist arrest.
Okay, here's the procedure.
I don't have any.
I don't have any stolen goods.
I think I sold all of them already.
Speak.
Nothing.
I got nothing to say to you.
All right, back to...
Back to Skingrad.
We have just one more person to kill.
Poison food does not work, unfortunately.
Loading in slowly but surely.
We killed one guy.
Arguably, I think he was the easier one.
I think the other brother is kind of difficult because he's got a brother.
You know?
The brother's got a brother and so it makes it kind of tough.
You think Tutius was the hardest?
Really?
Oh, here.
Tutius is the final boss of the game.
We can try with the dagger again.
On this guy.
We'll have a katana.
The blade of wo- Oh.
It's like really bad though.
Hmm.
This one has drain strength on strike and damage health on strike.
So, it might actually be worth it.
My bow needs repairing.
How do you see?
Oh, you're right.
Oh my gosh.
It has four left.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I can repair it myself.
Where's my thing?
Is it in here or in here?
Oh my gosh.
My bow almost broke.
Would have been so bad.
Where's the...
What's it called?
I don't even remember.
Oh, repair hammer.
Here we go.
Uh-oh.
That's right.
I forgot.
Chat summary says E.
Tina still needs to kill Sextius.
I just got here.
Is that true?
No!
We killed Sextius.
We killed.
We killed him.
He's dead.
Dunzo.
Gone.
Alright.
Well, um...
What's the Blade of Woe do?
Nothing.
Alright.
It's dagger time in the night.
I'm gonna stand here.
We'll sneak in from up here.
We'll sneak in from the door that I always go through on accident.
And while he's asleep...
We cut him.
We kill him.
I think.
So I'm gonna wait here until like midnight.
Yeah.
Countdown to his death.
But his other brother's gonna know.
That's what's so scary.
What if I just kill everybody?
Wait, it's open.
Hmm.
Are they awake?
Ah!
You're not the brother I need to kill.
Um...
I'm Gaston Cirilli.
Perhaps you've met my brother David.
Together we are the Cirilli Brothers Winery.
Uh...
You too.
But the door is open.
You can't get mad at me.
What if we wait like another two hours?
The lights are on?
That shouldn't matter.
Right?
Okay.
They will be asleep.
Sneak 100.
I saw some people saying that the Blade of Woe might be better.
But I think this one would be better, no?
Because it has more effects.
The Blade of Woe has nothing.
And they're the same damage.
I think.
Okay.
You just sleep with the door open.
And so do you.
Okay.
Uh...
Wait.
Open?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's something for later men.
Don't worry about it.
They're wrong.
Okay.
I want to make it shut up, but I'm stealing.
White noise machine.
Truly.
Okay.
So, I have a question.
If I go to kill this guy, would it be better if I'm sneaking while doing it?
Or if I...
Do I get a bonus if I sneak?
Kind of like with a bow and arrow.
This is Gaston?
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I sneak.
Okay.
They're the gods.
There's a psychopath on the loose.
Look out.
Brother!
Help!
I'm being attacked!
No, you're not!
Gaston!
Shut up!
You're being unruly.
Did we make it?
It's just auto-saved, so I'm kind of scared.
Check Bounty.
Just for stealing!
I'll never do it again, officer!
Oh my gosh, we totally sliced and diced that guy.
It's all over, Lawbreaker!
Your spree is at an end.
Oh, the Nernruz!
I'll take any stolen goods you have.
The next move is yours.
Pay your fine.
Or I'll haul you away.
Okay, you can take my gold.
I'm gonna make it all back anyway.
That's too bad.
I was hoping you'd resist arrest.
Okay.
Wait, no!
I don't want to go to the castle!
I'll die.
I
shouldn't have taken it.
Oh, where am I?
Wow, it's beautiful!
Wow!
Glarthor?
Our Nerdroot!
I love that you're playing more Oblivion.
I thought maybe you were done.
I might be...
I might be after this.
I'm not gonna lie.
I...
I've kind of seen...
Well, you know, I don't know everything about the game.
Obviously.
I've only seen...
things that I've wanted to see.
But...
I don't know.
I'll think about it.
It's comfy to watch.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna wait.
I'm just gonna wait here.
I'm just gonna...
La la la!
Uh...
What is it?
Like 12 hours?
No.
Just wait.
As long as you're having fun.
Yeah!
This playthrough got Glarthor and...
The most important things.
I know.
I was so excited.
I will always probably have it.
It's kind of like...
Okay.
When I don't know what to play, I would play Minecraft.
Oh, whoops.
Not the map.
Okay.
And now...
When I don't know what to play, I can play...
Oblivion.
Easy pick-up game.
Yeah.
Alright.
You should be here, what?
In like 30 minutes?
Yeah.
Oh!
You're here!
Have you...
done...
what I asked?
Yes.
They are all dead.
Really?
They're really...
dead?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm free!
I'm finally free!
Me too!
Of this damn quest!
This game is very much a big toy or sandbox, and I've had fun playing it.
Yeah!
By all means, I would have paid any amount to be rid of those watching eyes.
Always watching me, but never again!
I'm free!
Me too!
One thousand gold, baby!
Okay.
Oh.
Oops.
You dare attack me?
Do you think I got caught?
He's not running after me.
Where's Glarther's home again?
Grab his loot.
Oh, you're right, I forgot.
Happy as long as you're happy.
Thanks, Robin.
Who bought his key, right?
Why'd you kill him?
Because he's got more money in his house.
We own two houses now.
Where...
Oh, we're here.
Yippee!
It felt so good doing that, I'm not gonna lie.
Not gonna lie.
Felt good robbing him of all he's worth.
And...
Taking care of the problem.
Whoa.
Still got it, baby!
Sweet.
Oh, that's right.
He's got that stuff in there.
Okay.
Wait, do I have to...
Okay, yeah.
Where's all your money?
Oh, that's worth something.
Maybe it was in his pockets.
One gold.
Nice.
I like...
Are these showing up as, like, stolen items?
This one is.
Okay.
There's a few.
There's a few...
Okay, they are showing up as stolen.
Okay.
From red containers, yes.
We'll just go sell them at the...
The place.
The place with the guy.
I thought I remembered there being more money, but maybe he actually does just give it to you.
Ohaiyo!
Trash bin at the entrance.
Oh!
Every tiny bit counts.
Trash bin.
Holy moly!
Thank you!
800...
Gold in the garbage.
And also, he's just got little pieces of gold lying around his house.
A less rude song.
How much money do I have?
Two thousand!
Guys...
I think we got away with it.
Because it's Glarther.
It's because it's Glarther!
Nobody cares about him.
It's kind of sad, but you know.
It is what it is.
And then we go to...
It was here, right?
Or was it here?
That we could sell...
Maybe it was...
Bruma.
I think it was Bruma.
Bruma, yeah?
Okay, thanks guys.
What is it now?
Nothing!
My children are starving.
Please help.
Wait, it's down here, isn't it?
Hello.
Hello!
Maybe it wasn't down here.
Wait, what was the place called?
Here's my...
House for sale.
I have my own home.
Was it...
Olaf?
Olaf's.
How do you do?
The other way.
The lame tavern on the first floor.
Here we go!
Greetings!
Is it true what they're saying?
Is Banelan really dead?
Who's Banelan?
I don't think so.
Old Banelan is dead.
I hear it was a horrible accident.
He was resting in his chair.
Oh, yeah!
And boom!
A stuffed head fell on him.
I did that!
Is that so?
Poor Arnora.
Seems her boyfriend, Jorander, has stolen some gold from her and left her penniless.
Now he's in jail and she's destitute.
Hey.
Olaf.
Have a look around.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You won't find better prices in all Tamriel.
I'm here...
All items.
Huh?
Why is it not showing all the items?
Oh, it's Angar.
Good journey to you.
I always forget.
Wait, where's our guy then?
Excuse me!
Is he asleep?
Are you in here?
Angar?
I always forget.
I always think it's him because they, like, look similar.
Uh...
Could be at his house.
Dang it.
He's home!
That means he's probably asleep.
Angar!
Let's wait for...
Five hours.
He'll want his 10 a.m.
drink.
12 p.m.
Seems her boyfriend, Jorunda, has stolen some gold from her and left her penniless.
Now he's...
Alright, this is the last thing I'm gonna do, guys.
And then we'll...
We will...
Wrap it up.
Good afternoon.
Good news from Kvatch for a change.
The last of the...
Good news!
The gossip?
Good afternoon.
Any idea what Grom will do?
Now that Baelin is dead?
I hear you.
Everybody's just yelling.
That's not our person.
Where's our guy?
Hi.
Greetings, daughter of Steven.
I just wanna sell my stuff before I forget.
Unless you're like five hours.
Do you have the Thieves Guild quest that marks him for you?
Oh, we've already talked to him before.
Greetings to you.
Angar!
How do you do?
Stop, stop moving!
I'm really tired.
Can we get on with this?
Yeah, me too.
Pay off my fines and bounties.
Do I have fines?
I don't think so.
Wait.
Armand Kristoff and Scriva have special ar- They can make a- How do I sell my stuff?
He needs to be at home or in the inn.
Go inside!
Aren't you thirsty?
Angar the weary?
Stop.
Please.
Don't look at me anymore.
Okay.
Are you going home?
He doesn't do it.
I guess- I guess it's not wise to do illegal dealings outside in the open.
Greetings to you.
It's you.
No, no, please.
Is this your home?
Where's your home?
I'll help you get there.
Old man.
You can- you can even hold on to my arm and I'll guide you.
It's like an old lady crossing the street.
Get out of here before you get hurt.
Who the hell is Jerl?
Oh, I found it.
Okay.
All right.
Now we wait.
He's going in.
Actually, what if I meet him inside?
I'll meet you in there, Angar.
I dreamed you replaced the- Ah!
Emote and wouldn't say why.
Why did you?
We need to scream.
I felt horrible.
You need to take responsibility.
See?
It's not just- What?
You had a dream and you are mad at me and now you're mad at me in real life.
Cheese wedge.
Guys, what should I have for dinner?
What should I have for dinner?
I want to raid into Nimmi's 3D.
So...
Pizza.
Borgor.
I haven't had Borgor in a while.
Spaghetti!
Where the hell is he?
Is that him?
Yes.
Where are you going?
That's not your home.
I'm really tired.
Shadow hide you.
No!
Please!
Let's wait an hour.
What hour?
Let's see if he's home.
If he's not home, we go to the tavern.
Tavern.
Yes.
No!
Agar!
Sorry.
It's like...
Glitching so much.
Please, sir.
Go get a drink.
Oh my god.
It's a lady!
Hello there.
Not bad work for some folks.
Where did he go then?
I'm gonna cause an avalanche if I keep yelling.
You remind me of a witch I once knew.
I hate witches.
Agar!
A coin for an old beggar?
Good evening.
Good evening!
Have you seen a man?
He's skinny and sad.
Are you sure?
Agar!
He wasn't in his home.
For sure.
Okay.
I know I just peeked in for a second.
Oh gosh!
What is it?
Any idea what Grom will do now that old Baneland is dead?
Uh huh.
Good to see him.
Have you heard any word about the other provinces?
I've heard that Nord warriors have traveled from Skyrim...
I have no idea.
I think he's actually gone.
He got abducted!
Good evening!
Okay, maybe he's in here now that the lady is gone.
Good to see you!
Yeah, we're just gonna wait a few hours in his house, I think.
It might be...
I don't...
I don't know where he disappeared to.
Even if he's asleep, we'll just wake him up.
What is it?
Alright.
Like five hours.
It's like a normal thing to do.
Ungar?
Thank you so much for the tech gifted!
Thank you!
I'm so sorry.
I don't know how to pronounce your name.
But thank you!
Thank you!
Ungar?
Is he really gone?
Let me...
Let me try going back in time.
Thung!
Poftogabii!
Thank you!
My Minto gave ourselves the merch given today!
It seems like a lot of people are getting their merchend.
Thank you so much for ordering it.
froiding citizen!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Few!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my freaking god, Ongo.
Yes, please.
Take the things that I've stolen.
Do you know how hard it was searching for you?
Can we do 55?
You've made a good bit of gold.
Let's try 60.
Now that we're at 88, this position with him.
Okay.
56, my final offer.
Nice.
Was that it?
That's all I took?
All that for just two things?
I'm glad that's done.
Did you ever hear about the ghost of...
It's over.
We spent like five minutes at least searching for this guy.
Well, guys, thank you so much for Oblivion today!
Thank you!
I think the rest was coins.
I think so, too.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you for all the...
All the gifted, too.
I understand why you take a break, but I'm glad you got to see the Shivering Isle.
Thanks for all the Unhinged E-T-N-Adventures.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I should get my Gamersupps merch on Monday.
I'm so excited to drink some Liquid Minto.
Thanks, Sokken!
How can I help you?
Thank you guys for the stream.
Let me set it up so that it raids into Nimmies.
Waiting room.
Because she is debuting a new 3D model for summertime.
So...
It will surely be very cute.
And fun to...
To watch.
Thank you!
Also, Bogey, I don't know if your donut will come up.
I see it.
I don't know if it will come up because of the gifted.
Of the gifted members.
But thank you!
Happy Birthday!
We couldn't figure it out on time, but ignore that.
Wait.
Minto, I'm...
I'm taking you to the moon.
I'm on a NASA internship.
You are going to space.
Minky to the moon!
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you guys, when I see you next.
Next!
Next thing, thank you!
Atsubito!
Itadashai!
Have a good day, have a good night.
I'll see you later.
Bye-bye!
See you next time.